hey folks a quick note on this episode I
think you're really going to enjoy what
you hear there's a lot of provocative
stuff in here and at least one bombshell
I do have to tell you though that when
Alex and I recorded it we started a
discussion at the beginning that while
important is not the central focus of
our talk on Dark Horse so in the editing
process I'm having Zach move that first
half hour to the end of the podcast it's
still there I hope you listen to it and
enjoy it but I want you to get to the AI
stuff first and foremost so that's where
it's going to start and Zach is going to
do his best job editing it so that it
makes sense
but anyway shall we switch gears and
let's talk about uh AI llms AGI pauses
uh doomers all of those topics doomers
Boomers the whole shebang yeah you're
gonna have to help me with Boomers I
never quite remember what that is but
let's say a couple things up top in this
segment
a I want you to be
extra careful to try to talk
in English
right this is a topic
um that is so rich with technical detail
and with you know with an entire
culture's personal language of thought
problems that uh it's very easy to have
a an inside baseball discussion that
will lose average folks and so I think
one of the things that we should
Endeavor to do here is be very careful
to present this so that somebody who has
no background but is interested can
follow what is being argued about by
whom what are the different camps to the
extent there are camps what are the
assumptions that they share where do
they differ that kind of thing
so do you want to
um
you have
taken a number of people to task you've
called them I don't think you invented
the term but you've called them doomers
I've taken you to task for calling them
doomers because I think there are a lot
of us who believe that the dawning of
the AGI era contains a great many
hazards that could lead to something
extremely dire up to and including the
possibility of human extinction and so
if you call folks who are saying that
human extinction is a near certainty
doomers then the problem is it because
Doomer makes it sound like oh people who
see a very dire future it leaves those
of us who believe we are in very serious
trouble and better think very carefully
about our next move it leaves us sort of
artificially dismissed along with those
who say the risk is is a near certainty
right so let's talk about let's talk
about doomers good
um let's talk about the the term right
so as we've I mean we've spoken about
this privately but it's probably worth
articulating at least the the two uh
sides of that conversation so
um I look no term is perfect right
language is compression and lossy at
that
um right so there's always going to be
something you don't like about a
terminology me first uh you know me me
before most
um you know is wokeness the right way to
do it well you know there's a history of
that term in the black community do
those people are those people worth
packing up with you know what we call
you know no you know fundamentally it's
unfair to use any you know reductive
term to to group a set of people and
they might not all agree Etc however you
know for the purpose of communication
you need a label right so I mean what I
told you in private and what I uh I've
said a few times better when people ask
it's like okay well you know give me
something better like I I was playing
with the idea of like AI safetyists I I
think it's probably marginally better
but also I don't control the
conversation right I need symbols that
people will dereference in a way that is
useful if I say the Ia safety say the AI
safetists
um what will people think then you know
so so I ran a poll on Twitter actually
asking uh if I call somebody a Doomer if
somebody calls somebody a Doomer uh for
from the AI question what do you think
they are saying the other person uh
assigns as a likelihood of AI doom and I
was very happy to see that about three
quarters of people said above 50 so it
was either 50 plus or 95 plus it was
about split
um between these two camps our first
sponsor this week is Vivo barefoot shoes
made for feet
everyone should try these shoes most
shoes are made for someone's idea of
feet but not vivos vivos are made by
people with feet who know how to use
them and word is spreading people often
approach us because of the vivos we are
wearing saying they've heard they're
good and they are these shoes are every
bit as good as you've heard here at
Darkhorse we love them they are Beyond
comfortable the tactile feedback from
the surfaces you're walking on is
amazing and they cause no pain at all
because there are no pressure points
forcing your feet into odd positions
they are fantastic
our feet are the product of millions of
years of evolution humans evolve to walk
move and run Barefoot modern shoes that
are overly cushioned and strangely
shaped have negatively impacted foot
function and are contributing to a
Health crisis people move less than they
might in part because their shoes make
their feet hurt
enter Vivo barefoot Vivo barefoot shoes
are designed wide to provide natural
stability thin to enable you to feel
more and flexible to help you build your
natural strength from the ground up foot
strength increases by 60 in a matter of
months just by walking around in them
Vivo Barefoot has a great range of
Footwear for kids and adults and for
every activity from hiking to training
and everyday wear they're also a
certified B Corp that is pioneering
regenerative business principles and
their Footwear is produced using
sustainably sourced natural and recycled
materials with the aim to protect the
natural world so you can run wild upon
it
go to Vivo barefoot.com and use
Darkhorse 15 to get an exclusive 15 off
additionally all new customers get a 100
day free trial so you can see if you
love them as much as we do that's Vivo
b-a-r-e-f-o-o-t.com and use the code
darkhorse15 at checkout
our second sponsor for this episode is
Maddie's all-time favorite Sundays
Sundays makes dry dog food when they
approached us about being a sponsor we
were dubious Maddie our dog is a
labrador Labs will eat basically
anything what possible difference was
she going to show in interest between
her usual kibble a widely available
high-end brand and sundaes
we were wrong Maddie clearly loves the
food Sundays makes seriously loves it in
fact she's become Discerning in what she
wants to eat now she wants her Sundaes
why
Sundays is far better than the standard
burnt kibble that comprises most dry dog
food
Sundays is the first and only human
grade air dry dog food I don't think
Maddie knows that but it does make good
stuff it combines the nutrition and
taste of all natural human grade foods
with the ease of a zero prep ready to
eat formula Sundays is an amazing way to
feed your dog and in a pinch a person
too I have tried it it was all right
Sundays is easy for humans
as well no fridge no prep no cleanup no
gross wet dog food smells Sundaes is
gently air dried and ready to eat no
artificial binders synthetic additives
or general garbage seriously look at the
label all of Sunday's ingredients are
easy to pronounce except quinoa
and it's healthy for dogs to eat in a
blind taste test the taste test was
blind not the dogs Sundays outperformed
leading competitors 40-0
that sounds like a made-up number I know
but here's the thing when I have a bowl
of Maddie's previous food ready for her
she is certainly enthusiastic again
she's a lab
but when I have a bowl of Sundaes ready
for her it's a whole different level of
enthusiasm do you want to make your dog
happy with her diet and keep her healthy
try Sundays we've got a special deal for
our listeners receive 35 percent off
your first order go to sundays4dogs.com
Darkhorse use Darkhorse at checkout
that's
s-u-n-d-a-y-s-f-o-r-d-o-g-s.com forward
slash Dark Horse switch to Sundays and
feel good about what you are feeding
your dog our final sponsor for this
episode is House of macadamias trees
aren't edible but tree nuts are
delicious and nutritious they are
generally high in fat and low in
carbohydrates unlike what various food
pyramids and government agencies may
have led you to believe high fat low
carb foods are increasingly understood
to be both satiating and good for you
Greek species are not as different
requiring a special mindset and
appropriate Footwear you heard me for
many of us macadamias are the best nut
there is
macadamia nuts take a very long time to
grow however and because they are both
rare and highly sought after they have
the dubious distinction of being the
world's most expensive nut
between the taste and the health
benefits though they're worth it they
have even fewer carbohydrates than most
other nuts for instance half of what
cashews or pistachios have and
two-thirds of what almonds have which
makes them the perfect snack for
breaking a daily fast and controlling
blood glucose
they're also uniquely rich in omega-7s
including especially palmatoleic acid
and unsaturated fat that has been linked
to Natural collagen production fat loss
and heart health
and House of macadamias is intent on
making this amazing food accessible to
everyone they have partnered with more
than 90 farmers in Africa and now make
one-of-a-kind vegan keto and paleo
snacks these include their dark chopped
dark chocolate dipped macadamias and a
delicious assortment of bars made with
45 macadamia nuts in flavors including
salted caramel and chocolate coconut
but our favorite product of theirs is
the simple salted macadamias made with
namibian sea salt they are amazing we
love them and we think you will too
House of macadamias also makes a
delicious macadamia nut oil which is a
hundred percent cold pressed rich in
monounsaturated fatty acids and has a
higher smoke point than Olive Oil so it
is well suited to high heat cooking and
baking
and check out their new macadamia nut
Butters which are absolutely delicious
our house of academias Highly recommends
House of macadamias for all your
macadamic needs
for a limited time House of macadamias
is offering listeners a free box of
their best seller namibian sea salted
macadamia nuts worth 35 dollars with
your purchase at houseofmacademias.com
Darkhorse plus 20 off your whole order
with the code Darkhorse once again
that's
houseofmacademias.com
h-o-u-s-e-o-f-m-a-c-a-d-a-m-i-a-s.com
and use the code Darkhorse for twenty
percent off every order you won't be
sorry
so I think most people understand that
when I when you call somebody a Doomer
they think it's more likely than not
that we are dude right uh and just for
clarity's sake I also consider that
there is a serious chance of Doom
um some chance anyway that things go
really bad
um and in fact this is why I'm animated
because uh sadly the the
um kind of the and really that's where
AI safety is actually a better term in
pursuit of safety we are making things
less safe
um like with so many other things
um this sort of creation of panic in in
in in the public telling them about
um how you know some AI is going to
order viruses from a lab and they're
going to do these completely you know
very complicated things or whatever
could it happen sure but a thought
experiment is one thing in reality is a
very different thing I thought
experiment is not an experiment for
instance because you know you actually
have to get data back from not you to uh
to consider something an experiment but
um so unfortunately I think that the net
effect that this group of people who
have been preparing for this moment for
decades right they should have had
something and what they had was
uh you know ill-advised essays that
called for Extreme Measures some of them
more extreme than others uh some of them
more sort of policy worded than others
but all of them
um by my destination at best lead to a
world where 1984 is a Utopia we aspire
to let me put it that way yeah 1984 was
the best case scenario in the world
that's being promoted so look there are
a number of things to dissect here
um you and I are not in exactly the same
place with respect to what we think is
likely to come out of AI you and I are
in the same place as far as I know in
believing that the possibility of
something absolutely terrible coming out
of this is not small right it's it's
unacceptably large
right
um now I've laid out as you know a
taxonomy
uh
of five different
types of catastrophe that could come
from AGI three of which I believe to be
literally guaranteed they are going to
happen and are happening in fact even
pre-agi if that's where we are
so I might be farther down the road of
thinking we are headed for a disaster
and the disaster is certain but the
people you're calling doomers actually
believe human extinction is
extremely likely which is why they are
calling for
absolutely Draconian measures which you
and I agree
those measures are more likely to cause
uh catastrophe than to prevent it the
measures themselves are ill-considered
and I would there's one thing I
100 want on the table here
you've got a group of people who have
just come through
a most shocking piece of history in
which their toolkit should have set them
up to beat almost everyone and instead
they completely [__] it up
it's a good toolkit I used it it worked
it was a good toolkit and if they had
actually applied it to covid they would
have come out somewhere very different
they would have been much less welcome
at certain cocktail parties but they
would have been ahead of the curve
instead they botched it and worse they
never admitted it and so having just
demonstrated that whatever their
movement is composed of is incapable of
dealing with something as tractable as
covid
those same people are now demanding that
the world do absolutely Draconian things
you know including air strikes on
server firms effectively they want the
ability to declare war on people who do
things that they say are going to cause
Humanity to go extinct right they have
not demonstrated the mental discipline
to do this their model to the extent
that they have revealed it is full of
cheats and errors and inappropriate uses
of
um of principles and so it is therefore
very frightening to me at least to see
them
they should be very uncertain of where
we are and what to do about it right and
they should be working their way forward
from an uncertainty rather what they
have done is told everybody else you
should be uncertain and they have
doubled down on certainty and what they
are asking for those of us who
understand Game Theory complex systems
Etc are looking at and thinking holy
hell do you realize what you are
inviting right you are inviting a
disaster that might not otherwise happen
let's let's take a very simple approach
to risk and we're I'm sure we're going
to go many ways with this but let's
here's my very basic framework right
um risk comes because a naturally or
otherwise occurring single point of
failure or single point of control
um goes wrong right so let's say we all
depend on the Earth right the Earth is
our single point of failure if something
if an asteroid like big enough hits the
Earth We're gone because the Earth is a
Singapore in Failure what is a good way
to deal with that well you know you
might or might not agree with Elon I
know you're you've got your your doubts
but making life multi-planetary is kind
of that well then we've got the solar
system etc etc sure but you know for for
that limited question of like what makes
the Earth robust you know what what
makes us uh you know the earth a single
point of failure you can sort of reason
about that right yeah yeah hold on hold
on point of order it's very important to
me especially since Elon might see this
that he understands
I am not arguing it is not a very good
idea to make humans multi-planetary
my concern is that that is not a near
enough term solution that the biology on
mars or anywhere else is a tricky enough
problem that this does not deal with our
immediate crisis right
um you know in other words it's like
we've got a house fire and the proposal
is well what we need is a house built
out of different materials and it's like
okay but no we've got a house fire there
are people in that building it's burning
and it's like yeah but if that building
was made out of concrete you know and
it's like I don't want to talk about
building materials now I want to talk
about the house fire right right so
anyway my objection is not to be a
multitude I know it's it's nuanced and
yeah I didn't mean to imply that you are
yeah no one wasn't you I just wanted I
just want it clear yeah
um okay so so then you know that's
basically the same pattern as you say if
you say like well you know if you uh put
I don't know a single you know Institute
of Health of some nation in charge of
you know by extension the whole world
holds response to covid even if they
were staffed by the best people any
mistake they make is gonna go very far
it's the same problem with monocultures
right uh you know one virus gets in that
gets in everywhere all you know all of
these are the same thing existentials
risk existential risks exist because as
a civilization we have not weeded out
you know as you know all of the single
points of control a failure uh some of
which are single points of control that
we have created right so governments we
have created right to solve certain
problems but they themselves are
um juicy targets let's put it that way
um so in in that scope right my thought
and sort of where I'm aghast at my
fellow rationalist it's like if you are
discussing how to reduce existential
risk
um you could you couldn't possibly be
suggesting that we add a single point of
failure to the mix right we we
especially when you're talking about an
intelligent agent that can do what all
the other intelligent agents are doing
and try to capture that thing right
let's say we made a world AI
organization a yo
um you know for the spirit of the WTO
and who right
um do you think maybe that there is
enough literature on regulatory capture
that Nai that just woke up would be like
oh I know what to do you know let's get
an island somewhere on some planes I
mean I don't know it's kind of like you
don't need to go to you know Advanced
biology to to figure that one out so
let's let's uh let's make that perfectly
clear right first of all if
yodkowski himself
is famous for pointing out
the high likelihood that an AGI could
talk its way out of a safety protocol a
box that it was designed to contain it
right yep
so you're talking about a single point
of failure that an AGI would then have
as a Target and were it to capture that
thing it would have de facto control
over the board right over over any
competition that might arise because the
function of that International Energy
atomic energy uh commission whatever the
agency that's some Outlet proposed for
instance
um is to keep AIS below a certain
capability
so all you have to do is capture it and
make it effective uh so long as building
catch you like I mean it doesn't
it's exactly what in a business context
this would be obvious right you want to
hobble all of the competitors in their
crib right that's that's the game and
the idea that you're going to build the
mechanism whereby an AGI could do that
to its would-be
AGI competitors is foolhardy now I'm
troubled by the fact
that we find ourselves staring down the
barrel of the AGI era
and that we are now playing catch-up the
horses are out of the barn what are we
supposed to do about it and the answer
is
um I understand this isn't the time to
figure out what dumb [__] let the horses
out of the barn
but wow was that a big error right now
I'm not sure what to do about it I don't
know what the non-authoritarian uh
response is that might have contained
the uh the uh developing
technology that will produce AGI but
nonetheless
we are left playing a very difficult
game this thing now uh available in
public and the keys to how to produce it
more or less uh distributed about I know
there are details which are not but
um but anyway that's a that's a
difficult puzzle to solve on the other
hand watching again the folks who [__]
up covet so badly arguing for the
absolutely most Draconian reorganization
imaginable basically handing over power
to people who think that they've gamed
this through thoroughly have done some
obviously broken Math to produce a level
of certainty that would if they're
effectively like creating the inverse of
Pascal's wager in order to require us to
engage in a behavior that they think is
the right one but it's like you'd have
to be mad not to do what they think and
the answer is no actually I just
disagree with your Calculus
I'm not mad here's the thing right yes I
think he here's something very
interesting I learned over the last
couple of days most people in that
Community do not actually agree with
yukowski on the his estimate so his
estimate as articulated I believe in the
backless podcast though it might have
been in one of the other ones appeared
at the same in the same period he said
he's 99.5 and maybe a little bit more
sure that we're we're doomed right and
doom is a word that's used sort of as a
term of art as in we either go extinct
or we
um get kept in a zoo that we can't get
out of or like you know all sorts of bad
you know things that I don't want to get
further down that tree it's not
yeah the sort of thing that people want
to talk about but um you know what would
doomed like it's a bad outcome like we
we're in we're you know the possibility
of you know occupying Universe let's
let's call it is is permanently gone
um and and probably a lot worse than
that so
um
the the problem with that is that if I
if you believe that we are 99 99.5
doomed if I offer you and 99 doomed
scenario you would take it
it is an upgrade yep right and that is
really bad
so I want to call out to the
rationalists who think it's you know
it's 30 likely 20 likely you know I even
quibble with the idea of putting
percentages in these things but whatever
like let's just go with it
um
even if if you think that like please
understand you you think Eliezer
yakowski is mostly wrong and he would if
he would take a 30 risk when you think
the current risk is 20 he is advocating
for making your situation worse right
it's this is not a situation where it's
like well you know he's making people
aware of AI risk there's that's not that
kind of timeline
um yes people are going to be aware of
the Harris trust me
um the the point is to have a realistic
understanding of that risk so we don't
overreact and make things worse as we
have in similar situations in fact let's
get to that about uh the rationalism
covert because I think if they hear you
say they messed up covid I know what
they'll they'll say and I think I I want
to bring that up handle it and bring us
back here which is to say
um rationalists think they did excellent
during code because they
um picked up the signal early which is
true right by February uh in March
rationalists were all out buying masks
ever et cetera et cetera much earlier
than most people taking it seriously
great
um you know however from that sort of
Triumph
um the next thing they did is they gave
themselves to a modeling exercises
basically right
um a lot of rationalists or rational
adjacent money went to the Imperial
College for these uh sort of simulations
they were doing and these models etc etc
and and a lot of that was sort of built
on that and you know what a pandemic is
actually you know after we deal with the
original
horrible mistakes is pretty good for a
thing you model like honestly if you're
gonna model something you know how a
virus spreads in the population is a
pretty well understood problem and we
still did it pretty pretty poorly
um but that actually fed into this
um mindset that you can just go off in
your sort of crib
um on a notebook or on a computer and
like put some numbers down and know
what's gonna happen and first of all
that was wrong with covid uh for reasons
we can get into
um but secondly
you know right now the they have the
mindset that they've basically
discovered psycho history right they
kind of know the broad patterns of
history and how it's all gone and what
we should all do and we should just shut
up and listen
and like it is built on like layers and
layers and layers of bad assumptions
um reality is complicated complex
systems are complex
um you know just because you you know
what's I don't know what to eat to not
starve does not mean you can model uh
novel technology with Superior
intelligence uh five times down the
right Road or what regulatory
authorities are going to do if you bring
them into a conversation they
fundamentally do not understand you get
at best aisr Kamala uh and yeah then it
gets worse you you get that I mean yeah
for one thing there's no way that given
the level of capture you don't get
somebody who thinks oh what this level
of control
I can make a mint right it's it's not
even I mean it's not even worth it I
don't know the ring of power shows up
what do we do oh I don't I don't know
get Sauron involved right so I want to
come back to a couple things one
you said that you'd Kowski is 99 sure
we're doomed which is very different
than there is a 99 chance
that we are doomed it's subtle
but let's say that you are being sucked
over a waterfall right you're you're in
a canoe and you're being sucked over a
waterfall and you're paddling as hard as
you can
it there's a point at which there's no
amount of force you could generate
that's going to prevent you from going
over the falls right so that's a hundred
percent you're going over the falls
and you might be 99 sure that you're
past that point sounds like that's where
utkowski has us that's very different
than
you know 99 of the trajectories we might
take from here fail to save us but there
is one and we're looking for it right
the two you have to calculate those two
things differently but the other thing
I'm getting from this two of them is
you have to watch out for somebody who
has
99 Plus
percent chance of Doom either of the
versions I've just spelled out either
there's a 99 chance we are past the
point of no return or there's a 99
chance we will not succeed in escaping
either of those is essentially I mean I
know this well because I'm a guy who
um does very well in emergency
circumstances right at the point at
which you're 99 doomed there are things
that become very rational for you to
attempt that you would never consider if
you were only 90 percent
doomed right that's exactly and so wow
do I not want to hand over control
analytical or otherwise to anybody who's
so certain in circumstances in which you
really couldn't be so certain right the
uncertainties here are many and
um you know just a simple idea that he's
potentially doing the math wrong which
really looks to be the case the more you
scrutinize the analysis the more it
looks like it is
you know I I took him to task on uh
on Twitter and the podcast for treating
a complex system as a complicated system
and if you do that you get very
funny things
um out of your analysis for things
that will lead that will mislead you
dramatically and I'm reminded a little
bit about
um
you know about uh model brought and the
uh it's not really the discovery of
fractal math but the innovation of of
modern fractal geometry probably not the
degree of detail that you do so well
I'll I'll say it very simply right there
are some paradoxes that emerge if you
look at things like
um how long is the coastline of this
land mass
and it turns out that the finer a
measuring device you use the longer the
coastline is and an infinitely fine
measuring device says that the coastline
is infinitely long
um irrespective of the size of the
landmass and that can't be right they
can't all have an infinitely long
coastline so you need something that
deals with the fact that the finer you
measure the more convolutions there are
but that's not really adding to a uh a
linear calculation there's something
about
what is being calculated here where
the number of tiny fractional
possibilities that are being added up
and coming to uh effectively one
is not how you would do this calculation
right there are whole branches of the
tree that are being excluded here
because the one branch that's being
calculated is up being allowed to take
up the entire possibility space
uh and
all I would say is
doesn't have to be the exact description
of how you're getting a weird number out
of this but that number that he's
calculating in light of what we all know
ought to tell you there's too much
certainty here for the degree to which
none of us know where we are right
yes I mean here's here's how perhaps he
gets there and I'll I'll put a little
bit of a question mark but that's how I
understand it anyway so that's where the
foomers come in
um so foom is this idea much like a fire
that sort of just you know captures
something and then kind of goes boom
um that not only AI uh you know
self-improvement is possible so you get
an AGI that that can now program itself
better than
um humans could right hey it's it's
better at us at least that right so
therefore it can arbitrarily keep
upgrading itself and therefore
um it will become you know all-powerful
but that that will happen very quickly
right so it could be in in this in the
scope of seconds or minutes or hours or
even days or even a few weeks but not
years
um and definitely not you know decades
um so that's the foom position and from
that position you can sort sort of see
especially if you're convinced that a
you know
a super intelligence
um will you know that is that is a
Singleton as they call it it was it's
uncontested let's say it doesn't have a
uh something else that will stop it will
just you know do away with us because
hey why not or whatever and again we
can't really be that sure about that but
let's just say that that is sensible
right but you can sort of see how that
all holds together the problem is that
the way we got into this uh in reality
is these large language models which you
know do not appear to be agentic at all
they don't want anything right if they
want anything at all it is to compute
the next token as they call it find the
next word in it in a text I'm using the
word word with some Liberties here but
for most people that makes that's
roughly accurate
um but uh you know that's
and you can sort of see how that can be
used because well hey if you can do that
you can write code and Etc et cetera but
um the the important part is that you
know when we've tried to turn them into
agents right so we did this whole like
um Auto GPT or that somebody else made
chaos GPT or whatever baby AGI there's a
few projects on GitHub well they you
know besides the original like hey
that's amazing or whatever like they
don't work that well right like once
you've chain enough like uncertain tasks
on the back of the other the
uncertainties dominating the thing like
crashes and burns and it doesn't crash
and burn in a way that it like I don't
know takes over the world and kills us
all it just crashes and burns in like
the way programs crash like it just
doesn't do much maybe it spends 20 bucks
off your credit card will that be sorted
out
it totally could be like I'm not I'm not
here saying that this is not possible
what I'm saying is we still got room to
go and humans are still in charge mostly
and
um there there is Nuance in the path the
path matters right if it's a foom well
then the path does not matter because
um here we are sitting one day and the
next day the uh you know our new over
alerts announce their presence but the
way it is the the sequence of operations
matters and if you hear a lot of
yokowski's arguments there are well if a
super intelligence showed up it could
just you know what yeah sure but it's
not gonna just appear right I don't know
we have some Control Authority here
um to do stuff like figure out how it
works and
um you know take various adjustment
courses
um my and this is going to open up a
whole other path but my question is
about symbiosis right is is the are the
two even distinct is it even worth
talking about AGI versus human or should
we be talking about human plus AGI
um you know there's so much to talk
about that's my uh third of five
killer scenarios or deadly scenarios is
malevolent use of
AI
so that is human Plus
plus AI sorry I didn't mean to interrupt
you no but well but that's and that
brings us back to the single point of
failure thing right if we were saying we
would be dismantling all of these uh
sort of low-hanging fruit as they call
it like you know easy ways to World
dominance
um not because we are anarchists or you
know into radical Equity but because
well those things are the levers you do
not want you know the the checkout's
guns that you do not want on the stage
an all-powerful you know
criminal breaks into your house right
you don't want the gun just sitting
there hold it or throw it away do not
just leave it next next to the fireplace
from where from where the the thief is
gonna go right just don't do that uh so
yeah that's that's
um that's sort of where I get into the
whole um you know the sequence operation
matters feedback matters
um I think that's my difference actually
with most of the rationalists having run
a company for 10 years I understand the
the dynamic decision maker making and
that planning tends to go awry you don't
want to overplay you don't want to over
specify
um you want to be on your feet you uh
you know in my in my mind yokowski
should be furiously experimenting right
now with the latest technology to figure
out what we can find out not sort of
making overconfident predictions but
again I'm not I'm not going to tell them
what to do right like anybody can do
whatever they want the degree to which
I'm interested in all of that is a
degree to which uh there is panic spread
and that Panic will not be used by
yakovski but it will be used by others
who uh see the ring of power and will
move the appropriate appropriate levers
to shut the rest of us out and that's
really the where where the rubber is
it's not it's not about what you'd cast
key should or should not be doing
everyone has free to you know and he
knows more than most his perspective
belongs uh in in the discussion right
maybe he's right on the other hand
it's a question about listening to him
and acting on this suspect analysis
doing absolutely Draconian things that
you would never do if you weren't
effectively uh convinced that there was
nothing to lose which is where where he
seems to have taken us
um I wanna
uh ask you maybe this has come up in
conversation somewhere I have not seen
it yet
but I know that there is a chapter in
the history of rationalism that I think
actually belongs in the discussion of
how we should take this current claim
and that is the chapter of Rocco's
Basilisk can we talk about that
to the degree that I can articulate it
sure yeah you want to uh lay it out
yeah again I'm not current on it
um but I'll do my best to reconstruction
so uh Rocco's basilisk is this idea that
um
so okay before we get to that
um I will try very hard to not
um go sort of all technical but you'll
you'll help first of all Morocco's a guy
a rationalist
was the guy and he posted on something
uh let's add the human interest story
here Rocco is a guy who's basilisk was
the reason that
um Elon met his the Grimes so they they
both search for the same joke
I did not realize the Basilisk had
introduced those two but okay
interesting it does strange things that
basilisk um so whatever okay so let's
get let's get a little bit technical so
the idea the first idea is a causal
trade right and and this is like kind of
the hard one right so that
um two agents can cooperate over a gap
right this is something about their
space Gap this is something that Rocco
posted on Reddit or something less wrong
back in the day that's wrong back in the
day
um so there's two the the idea of a
causal trade I don't think comes from
Rocco the bass list does at causal trade
is comes from some somewhere in Game
Theory but the point is if two agents
understand each other sufficiently they
can do what the other wants on the uh
condition that the other agent will also
do what they want without any
conversation exchanging hands right like
exchanging sort of uh
you know get going across each other
right so so and and this is kind of
often thought in terms of like the speed
of light so if you've got you know like
a very large very large distances
um you don't even want to send any
message at all so you're kind of like
well you know what what you know what
would they do if they were cooperating
with me I should do that Etc and and if
they if they're not doing this is the
important part if they're not doing the
thing that I want them to be doing I
would want them to be doing based on my
fair calculation whatever
um when I get there I'll punish them
right so you kind of you've got two
people like you've got prisoners dilemma
but there is no communication and at
some point the walls are lifted right
um so you say well I don't want to
defect because if I do the fact yes I
get my benefit but then the other person
is gonna know
um and I should kind of do I should
affect my behavior business okay so we
we take all of that and again I
appreciate this can get complicated uh
but we take that idea uh and we say well
maybe the AI is already kind of posing
that Dilemma to us right so maybe it's
already saying that
um if you help me come into existence I
will reward you because hey that's
cooperation right with it
um but if you don't
and I'm just gonna
um that's the Basilisk right that's the
scary thought of
um if it is gonna happen then it is in
uh you know at the benefit of of people
today to make it come into existence
because
um us not doing that or not bringing it
to existence earlier uh will be seen as
a defection
let me keep it articulated like we let
more people die than they than there
should have been or whatever
so the idea is you could have
the emergence of cooperation without
communication over a distance based on
the fact that when there is no distance
the person on the other side of the
communication will behave in a way that
you can predict and that can be done in
time as well the ATI that does not exist
how will it feel about what I am doing
relative to bringing it into existence
at the point that it does arrive right
and so I better I better start working
now before there is Agi to make the AGI
happy when it arrives with my behavior
so that it doesn't hurt me right
something like that okay
yeah that's it's a good way to put it
okay I didn't mean to say like there's
something no no good enough all I I you
know for the relevance to the current
story
is not the details of Rocco's basilisk
what happened after Rocco posted this on
less wrong what year would that have
been roughly
it would have been early 2010s I don't
know if it was 2010 or 2011 or 2012. so
what happened
yukowski lost his mind he went at him
really hard
um in ways that I'd never seen like I
mean it was like all caps you know you
idiot or you kind of let the cat out of
the bag basically right by spreading
this knowledge you have now made it a
thing even if it wasn't even if that
deal was not extended well now people
know about it so they can't even claim
they didn't know
so therefore
so therefore that that
might
you making it more likely to happen
near certain As I understood the I mean
I only learned about this long after it
had happened but that the idea that
Rocco even posting this hypothetical
basically
condemned people to a future of
some kind of hell
if they did not start doing their best
to figure out what the AGI would want
and doing its bidding in a present
before the AGI arrived is that right
I don't know the certainty that he
expressed but he definitely
um was sure enough to cause a big scene
let's say right and to sort of get turn
a lot of people off so he must have
thought it was wasn't you know wasn't
the post
purged
and people forbidden to go looking
forward I think it was I think it was
yeah I don't know if Rocco was on board
with that or whatever I mean Rocco is on
good terms with yokowski now so I don't
know how all of that stuff that played
out but yeah it was it was sort of you
know banned and purged for a while or
what I mean it probably still is I don't
know it's in 100 places on the internet
right it's not right right look it
doesn't matter because I'm not really
interested in the Basilisk problem per
se
what I'm interested in is that it is a
early sign of a kind of
um
inappropriate thinking and inappropriate
interaction surrounding a problem that
is quite parallel to the one that we are
currently facing in other words I
believe that in evaluating
utkowski's view on uh the certainty of
our doom and therefore what the rational
behavior is that this is actually an
indicator of how this person behaves and
what they perceive to be an emergency
relative to something that they can
calculate that others don't necessarily
see in the same terms right I think the
point is this is our test case and it
tells us an awful lot right it tells us
I think
that this is a person who is so wrapped
up in their own thought process so
lacking in what I have heard you and
others call uh epistemic humility
that they
Panic they reach a conclusion about
which they are very certain and they
publicly panic over the fact that
something dire has occurred
that
[Music]
um
basically anyone who doesn't see it is a
fool
right yeah I mean if I'm still Manning
his position I would say he would say
that like he wanted to create a social
you know negative around doing things of
that nature now again that I don't think
that that was exactly how it played out
it was a lot more you know falling at
the mouth and a lot less you know the
next person who does this uh kind of
thing but again it's it's It All Leads
down an authoritarian path right because
what do you want to do you want to
control information and and the other
thing I want to say
I'm trying to think how to say it
because I I unfortunately don't have a
lot of the details but I think it's
important is that on the basis of such
ideas people in those circles have had
um pretty dramatic psychological events
right so this is not events
um I don't know if it's psychotic breaks
or stuff like that but like it these are
people who as they say for themselves
they take ideas seriously right and hey
I I you know I admire that but there is
a reason why most people don't because
most ideas are thinking seriously you
know there's a there's um sort of
whateverness baked in inside of us and
if you're able to disable enough of
those safeguards and like really believe
that something's gonna happen
um things can can I mean that can be
really powerful or
well really powerful but and not in kind
of the way you are intending yeah
okay
um
so the question then I guess you know I
I don't I don't mean to be
I I don't mean to be so focused on
YouTube in fact I wouldn't be focused on
him at all if he weren't
in my opinion pulling a fast one in
which he's saying look here's a scenario
either you get it in which case you'll
agree with me about what needs to happen
or you don't get it in which case you're
not smart enough to get it so basically
it's a cheat that results in everybody
who gets it knows that what we have to
do next and the people who don't get it
are the obstacles you know forgive me
for being traumatized over being told a
thousand times that we had a pandemic of
the unvaccinated right it's like that
kind of trick where you create this idea
that anybody who doesn't see the world
as you do is the obstacle to all of our
well-being
what
it's kind of your predicament yeah
exactly
um but nonetheless I don't like
this is not how I would expect somebody
who actually did spot an emergency that
other people didn't see this is not how
I would expect them to behave right
I would say especially if you had 20
years to prepare for that moment
yeah that's a good point nothing I would
expect something a little bit more
polished at the very least like some
some something more thought out than hey
not even polished I would uh be suspect
of Polish but I would say uh something
more persuasive and less manipulative
yeah it's a it's a Anyway by the way for
people who might be watching this and
saying you know what are the
Alternatives I do want to point people
to uh Paul Cristiano who you know is
definitely not unconcerned I think is
probably that something goes wrong is in
the
um I don't know 20 to 40 ranges call it
maybe even a little bit above some days
um but I think sub 50 is important I
think 50 is a very important yeah it's a
very important Tipping Point
um and he has made actual contributions
to the modern state of AI and he has
written
he yukowski has cited him as somebody
who gets it and has had long debates
with yokowski or something along those
lines and Paul Cristiano has written you
know very eloquent not like he's not
like me he's very you know measured in
this tone and stuff but he has said look
I I feel yukowski hand waves a lot in
some of his arguments I feel like you
know there's over he's overly certain I
feel like he he
um doesn't have full understanding of
The Cutting Edge of the field and he
downplays certain uh things that he
shouldn't
Etc et cetera which again is not to
knock anybody except if you know you're
shouting fire in a crowd which by the
way is not a free speech violation these
days mind you
um but um just to say but you know like
the
again I support basically look I support
the lasers
um right to say all of that stuff but I
think the correct response is to
what we're doing which is to
speak the opposing uh view that is no
we're not that doomed
um unless we make it uh you know unless
we actually take actions that will
concentrate all of the risk in one place
and just offer a juicy soft target to a
an AI that maybe is not that capable oh
I have a terrible idea
we can put it on an island
no that's a truly terrible idea
a terrible interpretation of the present
I would like to get you I mean as long
as we're over here in this territory
go for it liaison
believes
in Rocco's basilisk
you got it
yeah I mean hey I can't rule it out so
let me spell that out for others I'm
glad you got it immediately you tell me
if I uh if you in fact have what I'm
about interesting yeah
bellies are yudkowski believes in
Rocco's basilisk and he also believes
the AGI era is about to Dawn and
therefore the AGI is coming and is going
to look at Eleazar yudkowski and say
well what have you done for me
Eliezer utkowski had better get the
world to create a single point of
failure that the AGI can capture right
that is the way Eliezer is going to
survive the AI apocalypse is by being
the ai's right-hand man and he is now
doing its bidding to make the world more
vulnerable
you know
um
I've heard you know
it explains a lot
it could he's totally capable of of of
conceiving that thought
um you know how could he not have he
probably has
um so I don't I don't know I mean it
makes sense
you know I feel like there's an Occam's
razor violation here on the other hand I
can't tell you what is a similar
explanation so no no no let me be
perfectly clear
I don't think that's what he's doing
but the point is when somebody has had
the reaction to Rocco's basilisk that
utkowski has and then the AGI era is
upon us and he is arguing for things
that
uh will make us seem to make matters
worse and doing everything in his power
to persuade us that actually we must
take these actions
um because the certainties are so high
that is at least consistent with the
idea that he is in fact covering his own
ass
uh in light of the fact that he thinks
the AI is about to be in charge and
um you know it's going to view US
differently based on what we've done in
this moment
um
existing I think it's a meme well it is
I think it is also just worth pointing
out
hey Eliezer
you've put these things on the table if
we put them together they add up with a
possibility that let's say that you're
not doing this right just recognize that
some things some arguments you have made
very forcefully when put together create
a third argument about what you yourself
are doing in the present which requires
us to ignore you
well well for sure but uh here's the
Here's the the the what what makes that
argument you know as plausible as it is
um which is that
you know let's just accept for the
purposes of this argument that
probability of Doom is where it is or
whatever
um the question is how do you know that
your proposed remedy is going to make
things better
right because you know for somebody who
demands you know a very rigorous proof
formal proof if possible you know very
detailed argumentation for you know why
AI risk is not that high or is lower or
is it very low or it can't happen or
whatever right and some of his critics
are just not very informed critics right
and so a lot of the arguments he gets
are not very good arguments I get it
okay now let's go on the other side of
the Ledger right he is advocating for
um I mean I don't even know if he would
agree that he is advocating for it but
that's what he put out if you read this
essay at Time Magazine what did he
suggest he suggested a a multi-country
treaty
um let's say I think the the example
countries you mentioned this the US and
China right that would agree that they
would perform a preemptive strike on
Russia on a non-signatory country this
is very important right so the treaty
part is almost like a coalition of the
world it doesn't really the treaty part
doesn't really matter in this case it is
a bunch we could say the 50 states of
the United States got together and
trying to treat sure the point is
there's a there's a bunch of the world
right that gets together and says
whoever else
we we're not going to develop AI but who
if we catch anybody else we're coming
for you right that is the the plan that
was put forth in the Time Magazine essay
and and and the question is
um so so basically that requires right
this sort of international atomic energy
uh
uh agency whatever I don't know that the
name
um the
e-i-i-e-i-e-a-i uh I think anyway
um
that that sort of international
monitoring body right to go everywhere
and check everybody's you know data
centers and GPU production and people
have said like all GPU production should
be should be tracked people have
suggested that we stop you know GPU
production for 10 years all sorts of
crazy things but like
um the the point is if you build that
centralized Control Authority right then
you have that problem and there's no way
a problem well um yeah AI lockdown right
it's the same idea like stop the world
basically like is the is the is the the
vibe it
yeah it uh but but but but but much like
the lockdowns where is the case like
it's like we'll do that and it'll stop
okay but why do you believe what you
believe this is a key rationalist
question why do you think it will do
that
because I've got a lot of evidence for
you man of like so many things that went
the opposite not not that didn't work
they went yeah how could it possibly go
right
right especially in a world with with
AGI without without AGI it still adds an
extra single point of failure okay with
AGI it's like throwing gasoline on the
fire and I must tell you even hearing
you describe what I had already you know
read in his Time magazine article
if you then take the yes tongue-in-cheek
interpretation that he might be doing
the agi's evil bidding uh for his own
reasons and that that's why he's
advocating these things which again it's
not what I believe he's actually doing
like I take him in his word but I cannot
put aside that if I take everything I
know about his thought process that it
would make perfect sense for him to do
this but if you do that then what you
have just described is oh maybe the AGI
is going to want an Air Force
how are you going to get the AGI in Air
Force it's not easy because air forces
are expensive hard to come by people who
have them are not very likely to cough
them up well you need a a rationale and
this would be it right you gotta have
air strikes on server Farms are the
rationale for the AGI to get airplanes
so anyway again I am not
I'm not arguing that this is what he's
doing it could be but what I'm arguing
is that the fact that this is a rational
interpretation of his behavior of the
reasons that he would make arguments
that to some of us look Preposterous
right this would be an explanation for
that and the fact that it would be means
either it's what he's doing in which
case we have an obligation to ignore it
or it's not what he's doing and there's
some large incorrect calculation at
least one of them buried somewhere in
this Matrix of things that he has
claimed are true
by the way before we I I you know I
don't really want to focus I don't even
know how much time I spent on on
specifically yakowski but um I just to
sort of deal with a possible objection
some people will say well you know isn't
that how the nuclear non-proliferation
non-proliferation treaty kind of works
anyway right that's that's one that
comes up often so let me put a few facts
on the table first of all there's 50
more uh nuclear armed Powers today than
when the notification treaty was signed
in 1970 secondly the signing of the
treaty is based on the fact that some
countries have nukes
right so let's let's transfer that
analogy over you would need some agis or
or super intelligence or whatever to
exist to make a credible threat to make
other people sign that treaty so you
know it doesn't really work like and
honestly all the nukes we have now have
been built after that time because it
didn't actually stop the US and the USSR
from building more nukes
um the peak was much later so you know
like that's not your that's not the
analogy you're you're looking at it's
also
um hard to make nukes right so the idea
that some kind of control coupled with
the difficulty in producing them
uh
would have some sort of a positive
benefit in a world that does not mirror
the AI world of today
it's a it's it's a not it's a it's a
terrible analogy let's put it we haven't
destroyed the smallpox we have yeah we
like people keep like to keep powerful
things like there's that's not a like
Vladimir Putin's on the record in 2017
saying whoever controls AI will control
the world I don't know what world
they're you know yes it will that's the
sort of thing it will require it will
require World War right if you could get
a few powers to be seen but people are
not the US and the USSR well Russia
today
um not the what YouTube channel
um are have not destroyed their
samples of smallpox right like if you
know you tell me what the beneficial use
of that is I can tell you many
beneficial uses of AI right but we we're
people are just not in the power of
giving up not in the not in the habit of
giving up things that yield power so
you know the the the the non-workiness
of that idea
um and you know what will happen
actually let's let's put it up let's put
on a table too
um so there was this AI pause letter
right that that was circulated and they
said you know we want for at least six
months I want to highlight the letter
said at least six months not six months
at least six months uh pause right as
again as if there's like some sort of
switch that can be pressed somewhere and
that will apply to uh the Chinese labs
and the secret NSA facilities and the
you know the the uh under under uh the
basement uh Labs under the Kremlin and
whatever
um but whatever they uh what happens is
that the research goes under underwater
right it goes to places where we can't
see it it will go to places where people
can't make arguments about why it's
unsafe
um and just to give you an example that
very letter cited certain things that
were successful examples of pausing
research one of the things that cited
was gain a function research
I'm I mean
you know I wish I was making this up but
literally their example of a pause
technology was gain a function research
what for anybody who's watching this is
not followed along
um even if we accept that gain of
function research that particular gain
of function research did not give rise
to SARS Cove too what we do know is that
that research was outsourced by the
National Institutes of Health in the
United States to China and that that
very pause was a factor in that
Outsourcing because they just couldn't
do it here so they gave it to other
Wuhan instead of virology which
um instead of doing that research on
their bsl4 facility did that research in
their bsl2 facility what is a bsl2
facility you might ask
it's let's say it's got the biosecurity
level of your dentist's office right
something like that right like I mean
and they said well you know it wasn't I
don't know there was some some
complicated argument but that knowledge
made several top virologists who were
previously supporting wav to say okay no
that is wait you didn't tell me that
right I thought you were doing BSL for
point being here's an example where this
pause led to a drop in safety
um hidden from everybody even if even if
you don't believe that sarskov 2 came
out of that research right just that
they were doing me since I was like God
damn similar to that particular you know
that particular output
um Everybody agrees that that was a drop
in safety that that should not have
happened but why did it happen well
because we said well the US is not going
to do that work unilaterally we're just
going to step back right
um so you know I think people should
really study these examples should
really truly try to understand what that
means because you know there's this sort
of almost magical belief in regulation
and treaties that they'll do something
and it's just not not the experience
yeah now anybody who uh believes that I
mean look I'm a died in the wall liberal
I believe good governance is uh the key
to a truly free society and that uh wise
regulation is the mechanism that
produces a society in which uh negative
externalities are reduced to a tolerable
level etc etc etc but there's no way on
Earth that I want any of these
Regulators further empowered in this era
because I've seen that that power under
capture is a huge fraction of the
problem and there's just no indication
that the folks proposing this in the AI
context
understand the degree of capture or have
any answer to how it is that it would be
excluded from this set of regulations
and
I just don't think they have the goods
I mean that this is what I've been
pressing everybody on and what I'm
hearing back is just not
all right so let us
um move on to what I think should be our
next
topic
you and I have had a
friendly argument going about the
value
of the donning AI versus the horror of
the donning AI and I don't want a
caricature either one of us here both of
us see both things there are things that
this AI liberates us from that are truly
or this proto-ai
liberates us from that are truly
remarkable and very positive some things
that have been Wicked problems dogging
Humanity for for since the dawning of
the technological age let us say
and then there are other things in which
this opens fresh Horrors that we may
soon face and the question is a is it
just going to be a chaos and we're going
to find out
um what the balance is is the balance
positive or negative over time can we
deduce that the balance might be
reliably more positive than negative
based on uh you know some kind of
related rates calculation or the reverse
could can we say that actually yes this
is going to be more harmful than it is
beneficial even though the benefits are
real as we've seen with many
Technologies right we've seen that with
smartphones we've seen it with the
internet including and especially social
media right I don't think any any
rational person should argue that a
smartphone has not provided tremendous
benefits to to humans it really has but
the net effect May well be deeply
negative so are we looking at another
one of those anyway you and I have been
arguing back and forth about that and I
believe we've gotten to some interesting
interesting places you want to lay out
your perspective on the positives and
negatives of the AI that appears to be
emerging
yeah so let's putting aside sort of the
the medium long-term risks of you know
just you know world ending scenarios
right like let's leave those aside for
for the moment there are other things
that this technology can do that are not
very uh desirable at least from where I
stand I'm sure some people will find
desirable
um in particular
um here's an experiment I ran right this
is not something I read somewhere that I
just did it for myself right just ran
into this
um I took a podcast right not a podcast
from you a podcast from Z dog and pull
off it right like the the you know the
kind of the establishment contrarian
types let's call it right and I asked so
I put the whole um sort of transcript
into uh chatgpt and I asked uh tell me
where the speakers diverge from the
mainstream consensus
okay
this was the question I asked and it's
here you go right they talked about
covered vaccines and first fertility uh
here you go right and um that's that is
shocking right the the degree of uh
censorship that this technology enables
is a wet dream to the people who are
trying to do this with probably the
precursors of the technology during
covid
um it can you know like sometimes they
say well you know censorship is fine
because you know it creates art because
we speak in in subtext and you know uh
read between the lines this thing can
read between the lines
right this thing can explain jokes give
it a joke ask it to explain it to you it
will do that
um so it's you know it's it's it's it's
it's really you know I I never was fully
convinced by 1984 because you could
always you know the idea of a Newspeak
right that a bad thought was not
possible and you speak because I said
hey I can always say big brother double
plus I'm good right
okay so the idea of revolutionary
thought not being thinkable in Newspeak
it didn't make full sense to me but here
you can wipe out the concept
right you can you can if you can get in
the wires right between people you can
eliminate classes of conceptual
conversation even if you have the
thought yourself for the first time
you'll think you're crazy because nobody
else is going to be saying bad stuff
even if they were also thinking it right
um so okay after this Vivid example of
why exactly I'm truly worried even if
existentialists are out of the picture
about this technology being uh captured
by the very people who are doing this
very thing this very moment uh you know
the the you know giving them you know a
10x incapability boost or more probably
uh why that might be a bad idea it can
do good things as well right
um the sorts of things I've been able to
do for example the example where it
reads between the lines is clearly a
good thing
it is a thing right which could be good
or bad depending how it's used well the
thing that worries me about it is that
there's an arms race that will unfold
and the technology to the extent that it
can point to the places where
uh where offut and z-dog are uh off
narrative
um also allows one to use it as a
refinement technique for making
manipulation so subtle that it can't be
detected right
that's that's exactly the class of
attacks it enables yeah and so to me
um
I'm concerned that there are some basic
features of the universe that say that
those who wish to use this for ill will
outmatch those who wish to use it for
good although both of them will find it
useful
the fact is those who wish
to articulate the truth have a limited
uh canvas on which to paint
and those who wish to obscure the truth
effectively have the rest of the design
space and I'm concerned that therefore
what we you know this is a loose analogy
but what we can expect to come out of
the uh AI amplifier of both of their
power is a greater amplification for the
liars and propagandists than for the
truth tellers
um and I think it is if you're a truth
teller and you
check out the first round of the arms
race you may be very happy with what
comes out of it but I think the point is
uh it's a short ride before you get to
the point where you know as as I argued
on an episode of Dark Horse with Heather
we're going to come to the place where
the only rational thing to do is not
believe anything and my point is that is
better than believing stuff but
absolutely unsustainable
not believing stuff is not a way you can
live
so
okay
um I think if you see every fact as
being a vote in a ballot then you're
right right there it is the the number
of possible facts is infinitely larger
uh I hear Patterson screaming in my ear
big number larger than
um sort of the the true facts right so
obviously you can swap them out so the
question then becomes what do we do
um thankfully I've been thinking about
this problem for a good decade or I
don't know 15 years by now
um so I've got some what looks like good
news it's conditional good news right it
needs certain things to happen in
certain ways for that good news to take
to take effect but
um I don't remember who said it any very
well might have been Elias yakovski
um but there's this idea that all true
[__]
all true facts must align at least
that's how I say it the the idea exists
another place I don't know if you're
quoting me or not I have said all true
narratives must reconcile
the
rationalist Corpus somewhere and I'm not
sure I'm pretty sure it's echoing other
ideas because hey we're all climbing the
same Mountain we're going to get the
same Peaks
um but the the point of that is you know
if I can have my personal system okay
like sweep up facts from you know all
sorts of sources and I am looking for
essentially the largest set of facts
that
um are mutually compatible
then that you know broadest Network
um is going to be a network that that
must be biased towards truth because
those things match each other right a
lie is by definition in in tension with
something that happened right the things
that happen are always in agreement with
all the other things that happened
because it happened
I don't know how to put this this way so
but that kind of speaks to the the need
for this technology to be distributed to
be available to all
um it is a it's a like if you know I I I
understand the critique of positive
rights but this is one of them that is
gonna come out if it's not a human right
it's almost up there where we are just
it's just going to be essential for each
one of us to be
um armed
um if we want to bring the First
Amendment if we want to bring the second
whatever however you want to play it we
we need to be uh equipped with
artificial intelligence that that we
control that we tell it how to act that
we can uh audit to
um filter the outside world
um
I think you're missing something
okay let's play your scenario through
everybody gets an a an AGI that works on
their behalf well I I wouldn't I
wouldn't you it doesn't need to be
necessarily agentic right it doesn't
need to have a will it's just
think of it as a firewall
no I'm I'm thinking that the arms race
leads you to need it to have a will
that effectively if you imagine a world
in which everybody has uh an automaton
that simply does its bidding the way
your computer does
or did until
the bad people started algorithm
algorithming us to death but
um
that that then results in people who
have one that actually
um
mirrors their own values such that it
pursues their interests while not being
directed
will out-compete those that have one
that will simply do what it's being
asked
here's a question right yeah and this is
a tension inside the human
mind
um if asked right do you want the truth
or do you want an area that will make
you feel better
what will most like can can most people
bring themselves to consciously say
um I want a narrative
you know tell me a story I uh yeah I
know I've met someone I don't know what
most people will say but I know that
most people will choose their revealed
preference is for B
um
Perhaps Perhaps Perhaps it's a systemic
Distortion of a different nature that
that is what happens
um but the the the the point is that the
other the there's another element here
right it's that having more truth
there's a reason to want more truth
right and that's that it makes you more
capable
um
all else being equal it does oh yeah so
you know having and I mean you can see
it in the real world right who is the
most competent political operative is it
one that doesn't know what the other
side is thinking or is it one that
actually is pretty close to the truth
but you know is on your side
right there are forces basically that
are pulling things towards the center
um that aren't you know you know
self-delusion is useful to a point
it's not useful you know without measure
and anyway I think these these elements
all come together to
create at least possibilities right I'm
not
but the whole point is I think people
should be more uncertain like I'm not
here to say what's gonna happen yeah I'm
here to say these are these are
potentials they're opening up in front
of us and that's the the the kinds of
things that are possible there are some
really good things for instance uh we
talked about this briefly Iran you know
the uh it was a joke of course the the
a thing where you know I put in some
some proposal by somebody and just wrote
underneath what could possibly go wrong
right and it sure sure sure enough it
gave me a list of pretty good ideas
about what could go wrong some of which
I hadn't come up with right um and I'm
not saying that that is a verdict I'm
saying that that is a good checklist to
go through before doing something right
at least yeah it was a very powerful
demonstration of a capacity
uh of a useful capacity a way in which
the current llms can be consulted
about problems uh and the various risks
um delineated
it was pretty pretty cool stuff actually
I mean your example was something like
uh
I'm gonna have some
cereal with milk what could go wrong
and it gave you a pretty complete
analysis of various ways you know from
food allergies to choking uh that your
plan might be bad and then and then you
had it yeah you had it analyzed whether
the net risk from those things made it a
good or a bad plan and it gave you the
go ahead
yeah and again I'm not advocating for
anybody to actually use that as a follow
that blindly right use your use your
brains no no when it comes to cereal I
think that they could probably trust it
you know especially deduced
that were they to have a serious food
allergy that they would probably know it
already and therefore it was safe to
Green Light the plan because the person
himself could be trusted not to eat the
cereal if it wasn't good for them yeah
right and and so then I asked one of the
uh various some ideas about putting
sulfur in the atmosphere SO2 in the
atmosphere to like fight
what is it global warming or as I say
you know do the thing that that took out
the dinosaurs but do a little
um take the homeopathic approach to the
dinosaur extinction question
um
um but uh so it did not green light
that's not green light and again that
that's just two random examples right
it's not like it happened to be correct
on these ones it it might be right or
wrong and there's all sorts of biases in
this system we all like I'm not even
going to the thing you know it's been
trained to do certain things and certain
things not Etc right I'm not I'm just
saying it's an interesting it's a good
second opinion but even though it
suffers from the same things we suffer
right it is unable to see the future it
is at least able to do a more complete
job of gathering you know what could
possibly go wrong
um what else have I made it to I've I've
used it to create eight bridges across
scientific fields for instance right
I've there were certain principles that
I knew from historical analysis and law
I think the particular example I used
was the principal of embarrassment in in
historical and biblical analysis and
um admission against own interest I
think in law right that's the basically
those two things are basically the same
thing it's the idea that if you are
admitting something that doesn't help
you that that thing is probably you
wouldn't do it you're not doing it
because it's helping you by definition
so it's it's more likely to be true if
you read the gospels and they are
admitting something about themselves
that doesn't make them look good in the
local context that is more likely to be
true than some other thing that they're
writing that makes them look good that's
the idea right and this is same in in
law that if a witness says something
that makes them look bad that's more
likely to be true Etc okay
um but the idea that the same principle
existed in two places I was then able to
use it and say like give me more
questions content they gave me a bunch
of them across law and history right and
then I said well add another discipline
and it was like well here's journalism
right and it you know it added that and
it basically created this kind of
Rosetta Stone across different
disciplines and as we said it's really
good at translation oh no we haven't
said here but as we know it's really
good at translation
um so then you're like well it could you
be used for translation across fields
and long story short this is something
I've done in my life a lot right I've
gone into one field I've learned some
ideas and I've gone through some other
field and I've transferred some good
ideas that haven't made it yet so the
next thing you do is you say well what
epistemological ideas do exist in
history that do not exist in I don't
know entrepreneurship right let's what
what happens if we apply that boom you
know innovation of some of some variety
yep you get a huge burst of wealth
creation actually from leveraging what
has been discovered in one place in
places that are analogous yeah
absolutely I I had much of the same
experience doing my dissertation work
where I discovered there were things
that Engineers for example knew that
were perfectly relevant to biology that
biologists didn't even believe let alone
you know they couldn't accept actually
this belief yeah yeah active disbelief
so so yes that is that is a very
powerful thing that the llms are
apparently already capable of I will say
interestingly among the experiments that
you have uh revealed publicly
I saw one I think just today you put out
yet another uh children's book an
alphabet book uh uh where the llm uh so
the llm
created text and presumably you fed some
graphical AI
prompt and it created the pictures for
an alphabet book in which everything is
relevant to volcanoes right yeah so my
son is super into volcanoes right and
how would I find an alphabet book that's
about volcanoes like that's not the sort
of thing that exists so we were just
banging out here this morning and I was
like hey do you want to do that and you
know he he made choices right he was
like there was multiple options like I
like that one or whatever we could uh
play along but yeah so that's like I
think like making it a little bit I mean
it was it looked good to me and a lot of
people said it looked great to them
actually sometimes can I give you one
bit of critique it's not a complete of
you it's a critique of of the uh the AI
that you used
um
I'm somebody who
a has
written a bit of poetry not much but
enough to really know what's Difficult
about it
and getting the number of syllables and
the way you would naturally read it to
line up so that somebody who wasn't in
on the creation of the thing reads it
correctly it's very difficult and your
your AI failed at it right it came up
with lines that had the correct rhyme
right right but they did not have the
they did not have a parsable meter that
would have you know a an adult reading
it to a child could have fudged enough
to make it make sense but it did not
just you know
let me tell you a little bit about that
um so this is actually very important to
understand about what the uh language
models are doing right so when you
um for instance I can make it write
software for me right
um now here's something counterintuitive
you can do once you make it right
software you can say improve this
and it will improve that and you're like
why does this work like if you could do
something better why didn't you do it in
the first place yeah right but the thing
is that what it tries to do is not to do
the best at X it is literally just
trying to satisfy your request on some
you know regression to the mean kind of
way right which means that it's up to
you to constrain it enough to get
something valuable out of it what
happened this morning is I had an hour
right so I just like I used the first
thing it made for me I didn't you know
whatever I've done situations where I've
tried to make haikus right and I
actually put it through a a process like
make me multiple and then I used it to
judge the multiples against each other
and filter them out and create
variations like I even ran a somewhat
evolutionary process of like take the
best ones and combine them you know like
the best features on the best ones and
combine you can go a lot deeper and get
a lot better one actually funny thing is
that
um some somebody has found out that the
the human text tend to have tends to
have these two features called
perplexity and burstiness right long
story short we don't write sentences of
the same length right we so I wasn't
long ones and we we don't like to repeat
ourselves the llms don't care about that
so that's how AI text generator attacks
detectors
um figure out at the moment what is what
however you
tell it to do that and it will so you
know it gets weird uh but long story
short yes don't take that to be an
example of the best that can be done
with these things take it out to
something that can be done in you know
when you're not double checking what
you're doing just kind of like running
through it and yeah I mean the whole
thing was extremely impressive this was
the one thing about it that I thought ah
it's not quite there right so I'm not
saying that it couldn't be there if you
worked on a little more and refined The
Prompt and constrained it further or
simply somehow convinced it I am a
person who is Discerning about language
don't disappoint me make it sound good
you know
um so I don't know I don't know how
possible that is because I have not been
I've been deliberately avoiding messing
with this thing well that are some of
that are some of that stuff is actually
actually works some some of it is um you
can tell it I don't I haven't seen
research on this so I have a small
question but it does definitely seems to
me to work
um if you tell it you are a world-class
poet
and then do the thing it
'll actually make it better do you think
it would understand if I said
I'm a poet and I'm not even aware of it
uh what sorry what one more time bad
joke you're supposed to say I'm a poet
and I don't know it
but if you say I'm not even aware of it
then it doesn't doesn't work and I don't
know I find it funny but uh yep uh all
right cool so there are a lot of good
things that I see I can do today right
um the question is upon reflection how
does it all shake out and I'm not here
to tell anybody that um it's gonna it's
all gonna be okay or that it's all gonna
not be okay I think my main message is
to people to be less be less certain
um and and to not forget what we already
know okay not forget what we already
know is really important I would say
um
one of the things the more modern we
become
as humans the less often Panic is useful
Panic evolved for a reason there's no
question about it there are
circumstances in which it it works but
for a modern person
the number of places where it Panic gets
you into more trouble rather than less
trouble is huge right the fraction and
so to me this is a very serious moment
we are in we are in trouble as I say I
think there are five ways this could go
disastrously wrong and three of them are
guaranteed so I've just said three
disasters are coming I think no matter
what we do and I certainly understand
that I could be wrong about that but I'm
happy to enumerate
what the three disasters that are
guaranteed in my opinion are
not necessarily existential they could
be Amplified by something into
existential crisis but they're very
serious challenges uh for Humanity to
deal with
um but the
uh
thinking through this methodically while
we are here taking the time to think it
through carefully to figure out who has
a model that is predictive and uh
proceeding from there is clearly the
right thing to do no matter what and
avoiding Panic is I think top priority
the chances that we are going to panic
ourselves into a catastrophe that we
could otherwise avoid is uh is too high
it's unacceptably high
um I mean one thing I was advising
everybody during covet I wasn't saying
it as loudly perhaps that I should have
because I wasn't I hadn't ran it run it
through but now after covet I can tell
you it definitely would have been the
right idea is if you don't have
principles in an emergency you don't
have principles right what what are
principles right principles are things
you uh have pre-decided to do when
things are really you know up in the air
so you don't have to think right you
have committed yourself to certain you
know uh
arguably when when things are not
emergencies you might be able to say
like hey look I thought it through yes I
know I have this principle but in this
case I can make an exception that's fair
enough but especially in an emergency
when you know your your under duress
your mind is not working at the degree
that it should that is the exact point
where you go back to your principles
that's not the point where you throw out
your principles and you just do whatever
um and and and that definitely that
would have worked out like and and this
is what I'm worried about uh now people
are going to start uh saying things like
you know we gotta shut down you know all
of this or we're gonna constrain people
from doing that or are we oh you know
all the usual stuff of of people in in
in panic mode
um and I'm I'm really worried about that
and by the way talking about some of the
catastrophes right that are are going to
happen right like there's gonna is there
gonna be more fraud yes there's going to
be especially spiky like there's going
to be bouts before we adjust is there
going to be more sort of
um you know misinformation's information
mile information even whatever right uh
sure is there going to be
um you know all sorts of
um you know hacks let's call it like
sure
um here's something counterintuitive
about all that I think not only will it
happen but we should want it to
uh we should want it to because that the
these are this is how complex systems
adjust to information right this is how
we learn if there's small
um you know earthquakes let's call them
that are
um take or small forest fires right that
are taking out the uh um the the
kindling
um we should want that right we should
what we should not want as far as
civilization to continue exactly as it
is until one day something escapes from
a government lab of some some country or
other and it is it's got a cornucopia of
opportunities everywhere because nothing
was there to like prepare us
um and and and I'm pretty sure we're not
going to do that I'm pretty sure the the
moment there's like a few of those
examples to be touted people are going
to panic and we're going to start doing
really really counterproductive things
so if I can drag us to uh covet analogy
right
we did a tremendous amount of harm to
ourselves during covid attempting to
control the spread of the virus with
measures that never had that capacity in
principle and we told ourselves lies
about why we were doing it you know two
weeks to flatten the curve it wasn't
that we thought we were going to control
the virus what we were going to do is
preserve our hospital so that they would
have enough capacity for this huge flood
of sick people that was supposedly
coming their way right slow the thread
right and so that style of thinking
actually really what we faced we can now
say
at the point at which this was no longer
controllable
even in principle
right and I'm you know I have had a
debate with many people about whether or
not there was a point at which we could
have woken up to this and driven it
extinct I think that possibility existed
many people who are very well informed
disagree with me and I I honestly can't
say who's right I know why I think what
I think but let's put it aside for the
second there's a point after which it
was possible to drive it extinct
and the question is at the point that
the thing is circulating
you might very well be able to deploy
measures that adjust when people get
sick but effectively the point is people
are going to get the thing they're going
to develop immunity which will be
positive some people will be lost along
the way but it's hubris to imagine more
control over it than you actually do and
so one thing I hear you saying tell me
if I've got it wrong is
that there is something to be said some
of these things that are coming that are
negative
are actually not net negative especially
if they come maybe if we're going to
face a wave of abuses of this technology
facing them while the technology is
still cruder might cause us to
understand what it is that we need to
build in terms of countermeasures and so
nobody especially does not want to
invite these disasters but the
recognition that the disasters
are going to come that the degree to
which they are disastrous is still up in
the air and that there is some sort of
counter-intuitive question about when
you prefer to face this and what you
prefer the state of technology to be
when you do
um so I don't know how to I don't know
how to answer that but I do think
uh you know you've enumerated one of
them pretty well we've got what
malevolent people will do with this
technology that will be harmful to the
rest of us right
one we haven't touched on here or maybe
we've barely touched on it
is that I believe we are about to have a
sanity crisis and we were already pretty
Fragile on this front uh covet revealed
the craziness in people uh and it
revealed their willingness to go along
with uh
with Preposterous Notions at a level
that I had not seen in my lifetime for
sure but I believe that the
various versions of you know well are
you using reverse psychology on me or
maybe it's reverse reverse reverse
psychology you know that in a world of
AIS
that are informing people that you are
interacting with in different ways
the ability to know what's what and
which way is up
plummets
I'm terrified of the
ability of these AIS they're going to
generate
uh
they're going to generate what in a very
recently passed era would have counted
as evidence for things
right deep fixed are going to count as
evidence and then as people catch on
that evidence is no longer evidence
nothing is going to count as evidence
and I don't know how a world like that
functions right so I I think that one is
actually I'm I'm relatively less
concerned about that one and I'll tell
you why
um Photoshop is a thing yep right we've
learned we know not to trust photographs
right we just we just do
um and you know there's some experts
that apparently can tell but I mean I
don't know I can I don't know if it's
dowsing or if it's actual expertise
um but the point is that's not really a
problem for us why right because we use
provenance we don't just use oh a photo
exists we use the idea that where did it
come from to to to be important right
how did you get this right like what's
the story did you if you got a photo of
Elon from elon's feed right then that's
Elon or Elon wants you to think that
it's Elon at least you know that that
much
um you know the whole uh politician
being like I am blah blah and I approve
this message right that that sort of
thing is implicit in in Twitter
um it could be made more
um explicit by you know blockchain
technology where you know certain things
are in certain positions like a certain
event happened a certain time
um and there's no mathematical way to
like
manipulate that record that we know of
um but the this I I think ultimately
that's what it comes down to it's it's
kind of know where your information came
from
um but we already know not to believe
anything we see on the media right
people can make fake texts forever right
we've had fake photos okay now we're
gonna have fake sound and fake video
um
right but but again I think you're
making my point which is
there are going to be people who are
suckers
there are going to be people who
leverage this technology and figure out
how to
create the impression that something has
the signatures of a actual fact
um and The Savvy people
are going to stop believing anything
which I believe is like them cutting off
their nose despite their face
so by Savvy you kind of mean the midwits
of it you know Savvy savvy
no actually I mean something way worse
which is I think the best thing you can
do
in an environment in which very high
quality AIS are producing
uh phony reality
is to become cynical
about the idea of evidence
right in fact I would say
picks and it didn't happen
right right here's the so no but hold on
the point you know in a world where you
become cynical about the ability of
anything including your own eyes to tell
you what the hell is going on
um then the point is you're paralyzed
by your correct the game theory
paralyzes you
and I think what comes out of that is
for many different reasons it's going to
be a kind of insanity and it's going to
be very pernicious and broadly
distributed and you can take the
argument that you made for the last
thing and you can apply it here too and
you can say better we face that early
with more primitive Tech and that's
probably true but
it's still uh
I think a dire crisis that I cannot
imagine us avoiding at this point
yeah no like you I I've already baked in
a lot of crises ahead of us right before
we get to where we get to even if we get
to a good place
um what did I used to call it I used to
call the zebra build like it's a it's a
black bill for even even if there's a
white pill at the at the end of it
there's there's a black belt in the
middle and for people who are not into
pill discourse don't worry about it
um that's uh the the it it I I really do
think that yeah we're gonna have to sort
of these things are gonna happen and the
thing to do is not to panic but to build
defenses and both personal and
Collective defenses right build networks
with people you trust uh be more
entangled with the world so that you
notice uh these sorts of things for
instance one thing I did during the
pandemic by the way and this kind of
brings us all the way back to the
beginning with some conflicts I've had
um is you know whenever I spotted an
error I would actually tell people hey
you made this error in your blog post
right and that was a credible sign to me
if that person just went and fixed it
um that was like okay so not only have I
this person is clearly humble enough to
do that but now I can sort of trust that
they will probably do the same if
somebody else
um tells them so I can trust their
output a lot more because I've now
tested it if in fact with um IBM meta
one of the websites that you know is I I
went so far as to send them a um I don't
think they know this I suppose if they
see this they will uh I have I don't
know those people right I communicate
with them through a uh we don't know who
they are yeah
um but um I wrote a I wrote a correction
in a slightly you know very different
tone than I usually used to use with not
without my name and pointing out a
mistake that was you know against what
appeared to be there there appears to be
their preferred sort of direction right
and wouldn't you know it it I went back
a couple of days later it was fixed
right so now I know that these people
will even take adversarial comments
right with look formal and somewhat
vaguely threatening or whatever and
they'll be like I don't care it's good
information man like sure I'm gonna fix
it right so so so so there's there's
things you can do that are not commonly
done where you can take a little bit of
understanding right you okay you saw a
little error okay good you can bootstrap
that into oh now I know I can trust
these people right at least more I can I
can I can upgrade them right there
there's ways to get out of um you know
very noisy situations that
uh probably known but not evenly
distributed and again that's the the
work we have to do is is clean up the
commons and here's something else right
um the these things right the the
large-scale fakery of entire scientific
Fields right are are not new
as you know you and I agree I think
they're going to be democratized but
it's not like they're new
right people can do like most of the
things or even all the things that an
llm can do today you know gpt4 or even
4.5 or whatever are things people could
do it's just that it doesn't make it you
know it it it it's the stabilizing
because it allows you to put a lot more
what used to be effort right now no
longer effort a lot more optimization
power towards things that looks
relatively relatively trivial like I can
make a extremely well Illustrated uh
alphabet book for my son that is about
volcanoes and I can do it in an hour in
the morning right so so that's what's
stabilizing but there's there's nothing
that wasn't in principle possible uh at
least for the moment and and and there's
nothing Well much of that is are things
that the powers that be have been doing
already right so at least now we are
saved from the concept of even alleging
that this is happening being
um somewhat discrediting right because
it'll be easy to demonstrate
how one does that well so uh I've
alluded to it I think I should lay it
out I'm going to put my five
possible catastrophes on the table and
then I have two things that I want us to
come back to actually three things
that I want us to come back to before we
close this out so just so that it's here
in the podcast my five AI driven
catastrophes three of which are
guaranteed
are
malevolent AI where it decides that it
is our competitor and to to remove us or
enslave us or whatever
I don't think that's guaranteed but I
think it's possible
um misaligned Ai and nobody has yet told
me whether my first category is also
misaligned AI I suspect it probably is
um but misaligned AI is where an AI
isn't out to get you but it interprets
something uh you know the paperclip
maximizer example is the one that
circulates where you tell an AI to make
as many paper clips as possible and it
starts liquidating the universe to do it
because that's what you make paper clips
out of
um and so it's not malevolent but it's
definitely an existential threat I also
don't think that one's guaranteed but
possible and definitely worth
considering and being concerned about
and then the three that are guaranteed
are malevolent use of AI against decent
folk uh I think that is absolutely
certain and no doubt already
um happening
the second one that is guaranteed the
fourth one on this list is insanity that
will come from having something that has
access to the human API that is to say
AIS that speak English and whatever
language you happen to speak and speak
as if they have emotions and all of
those things and it will cause us to go
mad uh collectively and many of us
individually I think that's guaranteed
too and then the last of these the most
mundane is the destabilization you talk
of you know they're just the simple fact
that a huge number of people are
employed in professions that can now be
replaced by
an AI and that we have no backup plan
for uh how we are to run civilization
when most people have nothing productive
to contribute we've already had a hint
of that but we don't have it at the
scale that we're about to see it so
anyway those are my five malevolent uh
misaligned
abused
insanity and economic disruption and so
anyway I do think we're in a very
serious situation
you have persuaded me Alex
that there is another way to view so you
have embraced this technology you've
been playing with it you've done this
with your eyes open acknowledging that
there are very serious dangers here but
you've been trying to compel me about
all of the useful things that I should
understand
that it is capable of and I've
challenged you on okay that's all well
and good I believe the useful stuff
exists but the net effect here is so
frightening
um why are you not more concerned about
it do you want to lay out your position
you want me to remind you what you said
what do you think
um I mean you you'll tell me what answer
I gave you last time around but um I'll
I'll say a couple things I think I'm
doing it because I'm concerned right I
think
um the the capability like if we get out
of this somehow the answer is still in
the thing right it's it's it it's going
to be useful to get us out of it as in
the same way that it gets us you know in
more trouble like I don't I don't
foresee our prior State coping well with
that but then again I didn't foresee our
prior State coping well with itself you
know and and again I think we we share a
lot of
um priors there which is that you know
we were you know our civilization and I
speak like a technologist I know you
have different
um you get you get there in perhaps
slightly different ways but for me like
if you know how technology is built what
you or how organizations are built which
is another thing I've spent you know
many years thinking about
um what you know whenever you go into
the Sausage Factory right is is how many
things are built with you know duct tape
uh chewing gum uh whatever on top of
duct tape and chewing gum on top of
ducting like nothing that it's almost
like you see this thing is like there is
no way this works and yet somehow it
kind of sort of does but badly right and
everybody's suffering for it but it kind
of sort of keeps up and keeps going and
we add another layer on top and it gets
it maybe a little bit better for some
time until that gets worse too and you
see the you can see that anywhere from
like legislation to the kernel of the
Linux operating system that runs you
know basically the world or whatever all
of these things are you know these path
dependent uh piles of junk on top of
junk that kind of sort of would keep it
going you know barely right like because
if it stops working then somebody has to
dive in and fix it and we just keep we
just keep going but
collectively all that stuff is a Rubik's
cube right and we sorry
um Goldberg machine is what it is
completed the wrong token spread can you
believe it I don't know uh do better is
what I would tell us to hallucinate
right um anyway it's a it's a it's a
Rube Goldberg machine like our supply
chain for instance right that some
butterfly uh goes the wrong way in
Beijing and then
we just you know oh well I guess no uh
what was it like baby formula for you
it's like oh yeah no that was totally
foreseeable like the it was the baby for
me that was the most vulnerable
right and after the fact everybody's got
a story right about how the fda's
regulations blah blah blah you didn't
tell me that beforehand so please spare
me right like that's the the whole point
is that these things are extremely
fragile
um and barely working and and we keep we
keep we keep treating them like they're
not like we keep you know pushing them
harder and harder print more money you
know do more Wars whatever it is that
that we're doing that has systemic risk
right so I was honestly kind of resigned
to the fact that things are you know
here here's the problem I have as well
actually no no no no you haven't gotten
to the punch line of that one I think
people will be confused by what you've
just said
you have
a incredible
uh stacking of fragile components
that make these systems that work which
means they are uh
I've already used the word fragile but
the problem is you have all of this uh
path dependency what in biology might be
called historical contingency
that results in mechanisms that function
but that assume that everything about
the context is going to continue to be
what it is and you perturb the context
at all and it reveals all of this
fragility and you get cascading failures
right
and what your point I know because we've
talked about this is that llms and the
agis that will come out of them are
capable of telling you how to
reconstruct the system and remove all of
that path dependency so that your system
is robust and the point is that makes us
safer in the end
yeah now I would argue that this Cuts
both ways and it cuts both ways because
you're right about the historical
contingency or path dependency and the
huge danger that comes out of it but the
problem is
we are in that very spacecraft you have
described with the duct tape and the
bailing wire and we are about to
experience a massive set of disruptions
Downstream that are going to reveal
every one of those fragile links so as
much as the thing is in principle
capable of telling us how to revise the
system so that those things are no
longer a problem the first thing it's
going to do is it's going to trigger the
cascading failures
we're going to be pushed in a situation
where things are going to be failing and
we're going to be fixing them and we
sure hope that we get better at fixing
them than than failing at our normal
Pace there's zero way we could do that
thankfully we have llms so you know it
is it is going to be chaotic uh it is
going to be there's going to be
adjustments you know what is it
discovery of all sorts of Minima and
Maxima but we prior previously thought
we knew and all of a sudden they're
they're all yeah the the only thing I'm
saying is that there are and uh end
games or at least well mid games
um
visible where we have drastically
simplified the stack uh below our
conscious you know level of you know
everyday civilization uh and improved it
a lot uh right and and the thing with by
the way with with path dependency and
context dependency is not just that the
things that we have are made for today a
lot of the things are not made for today
right they were made for you know
there's Cobalt running in for the
banking system is run by Kobo like is
that because that's the best programming
language to use today hell no right it's
because somebody from IBM sold them a
Mainframe back in the 80s and that's
what they had and if it ain't broke
don't fix it and the year is 2023 right
um
great example here an llm is
fantastically capable of transferring
things between languages you can say
like can you take this code that nobody
wants to touch and the guy that wrote it
is dead right and we barely know how to
keep it running and just transform it
into a new language and it's gonna be
like sure boss here you go like it it is
phenomenally good at that right because
it's reality yeah I hadn't thought about
that but it's super cool because it can
even do it you tell me if I'm wrong but
it can even do it from
machine code
yep right from the compiled code it
could work reverse engineering basically
you can you don't you might not even
have the source code you might just have
the binaries right
an absolute nightmare for human
programmers right but again right it
cuts both ways because this also defeats
certain fragile but maybe barely working
security measures that people are using
to not get their code discovered right
they'll ship a binary
hey now I can take your binary and turn
it into source code again right what
happens in that world like basically the
way I describe it is that the the
friction weights have been radically
redistributed and people don't fully
understand that yet things it used to be
harder easy and things that used to be
easy are hard
um so it used to be easy to not send
people your source code you just send
them your binaries right and that gave
you security uh for your software
company well yeah that's gone
um you know there are certain things
that you could achieve in certain ways
that are adversarial to others basically
uh that are no longer possible right so
so so the disruption is I mean if
anything at all is guaranteed I know I I
say people should be more less certain
but the disruption I think is kind of
baked at this point
um yeah yeah
you know the the the bringer of Happy
Happy Joy Joy if any
no I I I appreciate that about you
you've never been there you've never
said anything about uh this not being
very very dangerous which left me a
little bit perplexed about your
enthusiasm for the good parts of it
until what you said to me when we talked
about this last time
was that you considered the trajectory
that we were on already so dangerous
that the the idea that something has
just emerged That Could That Could in
principle address the fundamental
fragility of the system was a good a net
good thing right that basically we are
we are headed somewhere dire and the
tools with which to fix the fundamental
problems have now emerged they've
emerged in a context that isn't safe and
Carries many dangers of its own but
nonetheless the capacity to fix the
dangers that we were stuck with uh
already is substantial and uh really
couldn't be more important which I
thought was an excellent and novel
argument as far as I know and I mean to
put it in game B terms
um hey we're here why not right
you know it gives the ability for novel
coordination mechanisms to emerge that
we just could not have pulled off right
the human firmware as I'm sure you know
given the title of the book you wrote
um Can can coordinate I don't know a few
hundred Souls the best you know how how
much you know the a lot of what we're
witnessing now is basically the evidence
of that it's failure to to operate at
you know billion scale
um
and and and really the the the the the
bull the bull case to use the financial
term here is that hey wouldn't it be
amazing if something could create
um a a an adjusting abstraction layer so
to speak that could actually scale our
native firmware make things feel natural
while we are coordinating 8 billion
people you know make our reputation
scale for instance right reputation used
to mean something you know people didn't
lie for a reason and turns out that's
the strategy of lying now
is is you know people do it less
honestly than they probably could
because we're still like going on
momentum but it it kind of works right
if you know what you're doing and if
you've done it enough you practice
enough you can do it well
um so but but but all of that used to be
kept in check and and my sort of bold
case for the um for for the people who
who who like complex systems it's not
that we will make nozzle systems I mean
we'll do some of that but maybe we can
kick some of the old systems back into
functional mode
yeah no I I like this idea too there are
many problems in Game Theory
that are actually trivially simple to
solve uh on paper and devilishly
difficult to solve in practice
um
and that this actually even you know
forget a billion people
even just solving a problem inside of an
organization so that people's interests
align can be very difficult because of
game theory that that upends you
um I can see obvious ways that even just
today you could have this thing build a
structure that would solve some of those
issues and that that could be a very
positive thing
um so anyway that's that's good stuff
um all right the two other things that I
wanted to get to before we close this
out
or I'm wondering as we're talking
uh thinking specifically about the
question of uh deep fakes and pictures
and not trusting any of that stuff I'm
wondering if film and possibly other
analog Technologies are about to make a
comeback because they might actually
provide an evidentiary value that cannot
be recovered in the digital world right
in other words the chaotic distribution
of silver grains in an Emulsion on film
is a much easier thing to establish is
organic than a set of pixels that could
have been individually placed by an AI
about an event that never took place
right in other words how do you how do
you get the silver grains on that film
to lie it's a much harder problem and
therefore if the film says something
it's much more likely to actually
represent something that took place in
front of a lens
so I'm not sure about that one but I
think it speaks to something that will
almost certainly have to happen which is
uh costly costly signals are about to
come back yeah right
um so you know I think we've been
spoiled by modernity being able to do
seemingly impossible things like you
know get a message from A to B
immediately and whatever right which um
you know is possible because we got
antennas but then you know again those
systems were good while they lasted and
now they're compromised right and and
not even everybody knows that they are
but whatever
um but at the end of the day if you
think about it a little bit more deeply
you just realize that
it was a cheat right it's a cheat in the
same way that you know using oil is
cheap not not I'm not talking about the
environmental element I'm talking about
like well it just so happened there was
all this energy buried in the Earth yeah
you've got it you've got all this
pent-up chemical energy from ancient
photosynthetic right right reactions
right right
um so we've got oh you know we we're
we're eating from you know the ready uh
sorry this is probably I'm probably
translating from Greek but like you know
we we are selling the silverware of of
various sort of domains
um and those were gonna run out uh now
they're gonna run out a lot faster but
ultimately I think what comes out of the
other side is some kind of you know a
lot more fundamentally stable things
will be needed right I hope we find them
I uh and again I'm if I'm maintaining
optimism I'm not maintaining options
because I you know I'm sure we're gonna
make it or anything uh but I think
that's just the you got to be able to
like see a game where you win right like
even if you think it's unlikely like you
know Elon famously
um thought that SpaceX had a 10 chance
of success now I guarantee you he wasn't
moping around every day that he was
running
that's right he was like let's make that
10 11. you know let's keep what is it
successful outcome yeah it's a famous
elonism right let's keep success as a
possible outcome here what do we have to
do right that's the question for me is
not like how how how doomed are we
um though again I recognize there are
definitely some really dangerous
scenarios from from prosaic to
um pretty you know imaginative uh the
question is what do we have to do to get
to the other side of this
um and let's let's let's do it I mean
what else are we gonna do we got
children we got you know family we've
got cultures that we've got to save
so
um
I mean I I agree with
I agree with that
motivation I would also add one thing
from evolutionary biology space which
will be well familiar to you
the fact is civilization you know we can
describe it as a collection of systems
that are linked together with uh duct
tape and baling wire and other
indications of uh path dependency we'd
also say it's a low Peak right we're
achieving a lot but we know that with
the same amount of input we could be
achieving a great deal more if we
weren't burdened and so what I would say
is
one of the insights that I'm
that is most important from evolutionary
theory
is that the moving from the low Peak to
a higher Peak
generally involves the transition
through a valley
and I know it has been useful in my own
navigation that means the valley tends
to be a place of uncertainty of great
danger
and a lot of confusion because it's not
the two-dimensional version of this
model that is often put on a chalkboard
it is a three-dimensional version in
which the Peaks are separated sometimes
by great distances the landscape is
shrouded in fog and you don't therefore
know what trajectory to take out of the
valley in order to find the peak and if
you take the wrong one
you can die without ever going back up
all right that doesn't sound very
helpful but my point the hopeful part is
Don't Panic just because you're staring
at a valley
staring at a valley may be the only way
to get to the higher Peak that you need
to get to in order to persist through
the next chapter and so I guess what I
would say is if we're going to improve
civilization it's no surprise to me that
we are facing tremendous Peril and if
the answer was that Peril was required
to get somewhere new then so be it let's
face the Peril and let us do it without
panicking because that's the the best
hope we've got
yep yep uh the um I believe the um the
embedding space of gpt4 I hope I don't
mess this up is 100
1536 dimensions so every concept is
mapped to uh you know when when Sam
Altman tweets a gradient descent can do
it
um which I guess in in your world is
great accent
um you know it's inverted but um it is
that uh he's talking about you know
moving in these you know thousand plus
dimensional spaces and
I think in those spaces my intuition is
is weak so I might say something silly
um but it you get you get both right you
get Peaks and value like some some
dimensions are receding While others are
you know uh going up and yeah that's
that's the way it is in biology it's not
the way we write it on the chalkboard
because you can't
um but but the fact is that's why
trade-offs are the important thing that
they are every creature is balancing
thousands of different considerations uh
simultaneously and so
um anyway the model feels oversimplified
but nonetheless it it it it goes to the
same place right it is not surprising
that we would face Peril on the way
towards possibly something better even
if right we are certainly not guaranteed
to find that next Foothill and start
climbing
right
um okay the last thing is you had a
model
that you were beginning to tell me about
before the podcast 12 uh things that you
think that we should be aware of I don't
want to steal your thunder so you want
to lay out your uh your framework
yeah so like we said
um let's let's leave this on a slightly
positive note I think that is the the
right note it's not wildly positive but
it is you know we're not just by saying
we can't create a world agency that will
control Ai and hope hope that that will
get us out alive
um that doesn't mean there's not things
we can't we can do so I've put this out
on on Twitter I think I'm going to
expand it a little bit and put it on my
on my sub stack but I put together 12
ideas and they're nowhere near a
complete set or an optimal set I just
wanted to put some thoughts down just to
have that out there
about what we can do uh today like
practical things
um that can be done to increase safety
from you know this coming disruption uh
but the critical constraint I put on
myself is without creating new single
points of failure that is you know that
is what I the requirement I set myself I
said okay what can we do without
creating you know the the the one ring
uh so for instance one of them was
um the idea of red teaming uh I don't
know if you if that is uh oh I use this
concept all the time yeah right uh so
this is a a white hat
right right fund people right to go out
and try to find all the ways in which
this thing can be bad open AI to their
credit has done a bunch of that
um hey we should be doing a ton like we
should be doing a ton more at all you
know every day all the time in all
directions we we probably you know I
don't I don't know what too much of it
looks like I know we're not right and
and the great thing about that is that
it's it's purely information accretive
like it's it's like here's the thing you
didn't know that could go wrong great
okay well now I know that it's it can't
you know it can't hurt like I mean I
could could Panic or whatever but like
assuming that's already a problem
um you know so another thing is
um a and I say this very carefully like
early model DARPA right not today's
DARPA like the early models where um
they would fund people with you know few
strings attached
um you know let a thousand flowers bloom
right I think this kind of approach
towards AI safety
um would help like let's get a lot of
crazy ideas and know that every out of
every thousand 999 will fail
um let's let people try things you know
if if it's you know three million dollar
proposals you know a thousand of them
that's three billion dollars what it you
know what's the cost of the 999 failing
to the to the benefit of one succeeding
right
um for for you know three billion
dollars which for you know government
scale is uh chicken feed uh apparently
it's what the Pentagon finds in in
revaluing the arms that sent Ukraine
um discover three billion dollars
um uh the third one and and this one
gets complicated and we don't really
have to do the whole list but I'll just
mention a few uh by my count and again I
know that you uh have your concerns and
which I share but I still think it's
probably worth trying is
um
try to see what integrated cognition
looks like where humans humans operate
as the agentic element right humans are
the willpower right and the AI is the um
sort of the amplifier let's call it
think of it as the Iron Man suit right
the Iron Man suit is under the direct
control of of of of of Tony Stark but it
you know he normally can't fly you know
he it's a it's a that's why I use the
the the the concept of an amplifier like
an llm as it is today and we are
exceedingly lucky this this was not
predicted right is a is a passive thing
that can like make you better right and
and yes it could turn like it could turn
differently over the future but hey can
we pause for a minute and and consider
that this thing has this really weird
property today of operating as an
intelligence amplifier so I hope uh I
don't I don't know where this goes but
you say it was not predicted okay I do
feel that in the essay that I wrote in
2016 which I believe you have read
um which is not public yet I'm going to
make it public as I've promised to do
and and there have been some delays
about the Practical side of that but
nonetheless uh I did
if I remember it correctly predict that
AGI was going to uh emerge from a
program that was not exactly like this
but was very close to it and
um so I don't know if that counts as
predicting if I think what you're saying
when you say it wasn't predicted it
wasn't predicted that an AGI would be
able to interact with regular folks who
could prompt it in their own language
i i as we kind of spoke offline I think
you're
um the model you presented
um you know it opens up a bouquet of
possibilities of how to do it and I
think what happened is actually one of
those like it fits that pattern yeah but
the interesting property I'm talking
about is the fact that it's kind of
sitting there right it's it's basically
a glorified lookup table it's not going
around and doing things doesn't want
anything like it's just kind of it
doesn't even it's not even really trying
to help you right I thought about this
the other day it's not even saying hey
it looks like you're struggling to do
this would you like me to help you no
it's just like here's an answer for your
question and that's that let me see if
uh
if I'm getting at the property you're
talking about correctly it's almost like
an ex
static Explorer
of the collective mind
where you can now walk into the
collective mind and you can say well
maybe here's a thought that we've never
brought to Consciousness before but
surely if we did some things would
emerge what would we say if we suddenly
became conscious of this question and
you can walk over to the quadrant in
this uh static rendering of our mind
which exists at some level of resolution
and no greater but anyway it's good
enough that you can walk over to some
fraction of the collective mind and see
what it would think about something and
get back an answer that is interpretable
the the um the mission statement of
Google
um I'm sure you know it by heart but
I might be one of the people that that
does is to organize the world's
information and make it universally
accessible and useful right
um this is yeah you know large language
models uh are
far closer to that sort of glorified
search engine uh Vibe right it's an
idealized search engine of sorts uh than
they are to you know you and me like
people right that's kind of what I'm
what I'm trying to get it it's like it's
going to give you information uh it can
exp yeah as you say it can reach into
all the little thought threads of
thought that we've put out there over
the years right it's kind of absorbed
all of them and turned them into a rope
um that it can sort of can access and
um can reach into it in weird ways that
we probably couldn't
um but um again it is genuinely strange
and and I guess what I'm saying is that
like while we're worried about the
agency element that will be strapped on
top of it at some point let's realize
that it can be the agency that it's
strapped onto could be human right like
there's um the way Elon says it about
neuralink and I know there's a lot of
controversy in the Neuroscience space
and whatever
um is that
um you know you got the don't know if
it's the basal ganglia or the lizard
brain or whatever you want to call it
the lower the more evolutionarily
ancient levels of the of the brain
um being somewhat in control of the of
the newer and and more capable ones the
question is can we turn you know these
uh Technologies into a third layer right
that that continues that pattern
um and I don't know if it's do I mean to
some degree it is this is what we're
doing right like when I play a guitar I
don't think about the guitar I think
about the sound I want to make right at
some point it's just absorbed into my
body plan
um and when we use you know sometimes uh
now I'll have a question and I I won't
like try to remember the answer I'll
just plug it into chat apt because I you
know that's kind of absorbed into my
body plan too apparently so the question
is can we do more of that and not
because we you know uh for the fun of it
though you know I'm sure there's going
to be some fun that comes of it
um but for the the purpose that if AGI
is Gonna Come I think it's in our uh uh
sort of interest to get there first
right the first thing is is is human
based rather than other base right and
uh that essay of mine that you read I
think suggests a mechanism
for doing this which anyway when I
deploy that essay I'm going to tack on a
modern addendum and talk about what I
think the path forward is for AI safety
um there's a bunch of these and we don't
have to go through the whole thing but
if people want to find it on Twitter I
have a tweet called my suggestions for
reducing AI risk without creating novel
single points of failure and there's a
bunch of ideas in there Perfect all
right
Alex I want to
start this is unkind of Me Maybe but you
and I are friends and I hope you will
trust me to do it I want to start by
taking you to task for something and I'm
doing this
for what I at least imagine is the
greater good
here's what I see
lots of people are becoming aware of you
I know
more than a couple of people who dislike
you intensely and see things in you that
I know aren't there because you and I
are friends you and I know each other in
person I know your marvelous family
there's no truth to what people imagine
must be going on with you and I think as
your friend I have a little insight into
what they have misunderstood but in
order to unpack this so that maybe
people will or those people who don't
like you will come around to a more
nuanced perspective
I do think that I need to make a point
to you too about why it is that you're
so easily misinterpreted
so uh your game
let's do it all right
so
what I see and you know you and I met
during covid you in fact were brought
into a project to evaluate whether the
accusations that were being leveled at
Heather and me were accurate that we
were uninformed spreading misinformation
about covet and you ran a project called
better Skeptics which evaluated the
claims that we had made errors and after
this project
um you and I came to know each other
the project itself concluded that there
were a few small places where we had
misstep but that in general we had been
very good about being accurate and where
we had been inaccurate correcting the
record of Our Own volition
and not needing to be taken to task
so in any case thank you for doing that
actually it meant a great deal to us
even if the world didn't hear much of
what you came up with if it's
um if it's a good use of time it's it is
I I do think back to the report we wrote
right after that uh project and because
and I think it says a lot and it
actually might even touch on the AI
question we will get to later but it it
proved to me that it is possible by just
sitting down and taking Authority
questions and varied inputs and going
into the sources to figure stuff out
that you know is completely counter to
the narrative and becomes stories later
right like so for instance when um the
the you know recently somebody one of
the Pfizer Executives said at the
European commission we didn't test it
for transmission and lots of people even
Elon I think someone's like why didn't
why wasn't this made clear it was it was
sorry but like forget what the public
health establishment said if you look at
the actual you know releases from the
Pharmaceuticals they said what they were
looking at like what they allowed to be
projected and what they did is a
different story but if you actually
looked at the sources uh same thing with
the uh the animal testing we you know it
was it true that there was absolutely no
safety testing no were there like
significant chunks skipped yes and that
was knowable you could get down to the
facts go to the source document and
confirm that at the time that document
to me is is a great uh Testament to the
fact that you you know you can sit down
you can take a very scientific or you
know journalistic or all the you know
all the things that have broken these
days approach and actually come to
conclusions that then you just sit and
watch everybody like slowly you know
converge to it it's it's wild but like
we did it so you know it can't must be
possible because because it was done I
actually think that that is one of the
biggest lessons of the entire
covered so-called pandemic is that these
topics were difficult but they were made
far more difficult than they needed to
be in fact you needed a basic
willingness to rationally evaluate and
to exert some kind of standard over what
information
you thought was credible enough to
process and then it was possible to
predict what was going to unfold predict
what people were going to come to
understand because
um you know some of us have trained to
understand complex things and this was
like every other complex thing it just
came with a lot more deception than you
know your average piece of biology let's
say
so
uh you know I saw you as a Force for
good you were unambiguously a Force for
good in the in in the covid era and I
guess it is no surprise that you would
have accumulated a great many detractors
in that period because anybody who was a
Force for good did
what troubles me is that some of your
detractors from that period
are not the bad people as I see it
they're not the liars and the shells and
the uh you know the the the phonies
they're people that themselves bring
something positive to the table and yet
you and they are like oil and water and
I wanted to say why I think that happens
and see if a I can get them to rethink
and B get you maybe to alter your mode
of interaction a little bit
so
what I see is this and you know of
course I know the backstory pretty well
because you and I become friends
you are maybe this is not the right way
to put it but a recovering rationalist I
think or you know you are a rationalist
and those who are called rationalists
are something else it turns out
and I think
you feel an obligation because it's
really part of the rationalist code
to hold other rationalists who are not
living up to that code to uh to the
standard right and to hold their feet to
the fire
and so there's a certain kind of
um Delight I see in you as you set the
record straight on people who are
rationalizing
about matters of life and death who are
demonizing the wrong folks because well
for whatever reason
um so in general I would say the
rationalists did an appalling job during
covet I mean just it it was so
disappointing to see people who whose
Credo effectively commits them to doing
dispassionate analysis
you know saying what needs to be said uh
analyzing the data and following the
evidence wherever it leads if that's the
flag you've planted in the ground and
then you don't do it
it's worse than having done nothing at
all because you've effectively
advertised that if there was something
up that just was way off and easily
detected you'd be the people to Spot It
and if you don't spot it or maybe you do
spot it and you rationalize not talking
about it because it's frightening to you
then you're doing harm right it it's
it's a case in which uh the absence of
rationalists sounding the alarm over the
absolute nonsense that was being
broadcast over covid suggests that that
nonsense was higher quality than it was
because surely the rationalists would
have spotted it if it wasn't
oh so it's worse than that they they by
my count they became the Stormtroopers
for the establishment right it was
um you know even without them like
saying something
um there was this group that you know uh
was advertising themselves as you know
who are you going to call Ghostbusters
but when they came they brought more
ghosts
um you know and and there's an you know
that group has you know and and people
will say we're not a group yet okay I
understand different there is a group
everybody knows what I'm talking about
okay
um and um if you advertise Yourself by
some moniker right and you draw status
by that moniker you draw
um attention by that moniker you draw a
respect moniker then you know yeah I I
see it as
um some kind of contract that you uh
have signed with you know the public and
that not and you know there's a lot of
people right have made monetary
contributions they have made time
contributions they've they've given
their their lives you know uh they've
certainly such substantially altered the
course of their lives for that movement
and you know having come to find that
um you know much like anything that you
know ends with ist I guess is is bound
to sort of reverse itself you know uh
for some some weird pattern but um
having seen that and and having
confirmed it for myself two rationalist
standards right beyond beyond any
reasonable doubt that
um unfortunately there's some weird
inversion going on
um yeah no uh
some people might see my interactions
and being like hey that was uncalled for
but it is in the middle of a longer
story I suppose that you kind of have to
yeah you weren't there man you would
understand it or something like that
right well look I get this and you know
as somebody whose reputation was
put completely on the line over covid
and you know I don't think there was any
way to avoid that I think as a biologist
uh who decided not to be silent about
this both Heather and I were in a
situation where we damn well better do
the work correctly uh or we're gonna in
big trouble so to do the work correctly
and then have the rationalists covering
their asses and uh rationalizing
themselves into nonsense and actually
being on the attack functioning as
Stormtroopers against us was uh it was
beyond disappointing and I certainly
understand you know I was never a
rationalist I always felt like a fellow
traveler of the rationalists but uh
as a rationalist yourself
I can imagine exactly why you would feel
an absolute obligation to hold other
people to the standards that you
collectively signed up for that makes
total sense to me that's and I and I
won't even take you to task for that
because you know that in some sense that
was you holding your own Community to
task and I thought you did it honorably
and well
the place that I think you got into some
trouble was that I think because it was
the same battle
that some other folks who weren't
rationalists
got the same
type of response and believe me I don't
uh I don't think you should have held
back holding people to account but I
think people who did not advertise
themselves as rationalists
um probably should have been dealt with
a little differently because in some
sense they didn't say hey we're the
people who are right for a living they
were just trying to navigate right and
so anyway what I would ask is that um
the
Delight that you I think evidenced in
setting uh your own Community straight
was a little off when it came to people
who had not broadcast their own
um extraordinary capability of finding
uh the needle in the haystack of
rationality right
so anyway does that make sense are you I
mean I need to know the uh the specifics
there is you know one sort of I guess
common acquaintance of ours famous
podcast host that I've come to the
loggerheads over I don't know if that's
the person you're thinking about
um well it would come down to the
specifics I'm look I I I'll say I'll say
a couple of things right so how do I use
Twitter because that's let's face it
that's where that's where all the things
happen right I
there's there's many ways to do it and
my Approach is to just be me and not
sort of try to overly sort of strategize
um whenever I you know there's a local
minimum of like just say what you think
right and then from there there are like
arbitrary complexity you can add on top
of it well you know whatever I try to
add as little of that as I uh I possibly
can because I don't fundamentally
believe in strategy in such a you know
um complicated environment I think you
know people rather let me put it this
way people tend to over strategize them
under strategy so I just try to be uh me
and I guess I've got a uh particular
benefit here because I'm not it's not my
my living at least not not for the
moment to to do that so I am basically
you know one of the one of the crowd and
I that you know that's kind of what I
what I do
the one thing I will say and I wonder if
people know that it's a feature in my in
my Twitter presence that might not be
something that people that are aware is
that you can always ask me like what do
you mean by that or you know what is
like just just double click on stuff if
you don't understand something don't
assume that I like I'll bite your face
off if like you ask me like I I
genuinely get into very deep thread
conversations with people because they
just ask me something and I try to
answer I mean well I see everything
probably not I try very hard to see
everything which is also why I block
people by the way right if somebody
um it replies something because I will
see it
um
I I see that as a as a investment
proposal for my time and if somebody
presents me with bad investment
proposals uh a few times I'll say you
know I will not no longer be uh sort of
looking at your investment proposals sir
thank you
um or Madam
um so you know so so I I but most people
at work and actually
um the sort of see their replies I uh I
I generally engage and that's what
people find it I I but I do realize that
that is uncommon when people might not
expect it but I I I tweet with that in
mind that if anybody has any question
about what I'm doing they can totally
just ask yeah I've both seen this and
experienced it you are absolutely ready
to both engage fill in details go back
and say I think I had this a little
wrong or you know
anyway I've found you to be an honest
broker in this regard and I think you
know I I think in some sense because you
are true to the I mean you know not that
I know exactly what the rationalist code
is but I I can infer it I think you are
true to that and I think the problem is
that other people are adhering to a kind
of different code in which
um
you know there's some obligation to
provide a face-saving exit or something
like that and if you just keep holding
somebody who is not a rationalist to a
standard and saying look you've got this
wrong and you don't give them some
mechanism to
come back around
um then I will say that I generally do
try to do that whenever you know there's
this term I don't know if you know it
flipping the bit uh have you heard this
before you flipped out on somebody
uh it's basically when you sort of like
okay well this person isn't really
they're lost like for for all intents
and purposes no you're just you're
throwing them in a different you there's
a bit that that encodes which category
they're in exactly yeah right so before
I do that I generally have tried again
the problem is with Twitter there's no
easy way to do context right and say
like okay let me see the interactions
between these two people over you know a
period of time even you know with Sam
Harris that's famously made a career of
going to podcasts and saying I'm a
psychopath or whatever
um if you see our earlier you know In
fairness to Sam uh you had no right to
put him in so much context I know
it was it was you know but the thing is
if you actually go back to the beginning
of the interaction
you'll see that my tone is very
different because I try and then you
know he took my initial thread uh he
commented on it he named me in his
podcast I was just somebody from the
crowd right he picked one thing uh that
he felt he had a strong claim on and he
misrepresented and then misanswered it
and then considered the whole thread
dealt with the thread that documented
him slandering people right he finds one
like little little claim that he feels
is like
um oh yeah I'm gonna hit him on that one
wrongly by the way because he came at me
on a an assistant on an information
systems design question not knowing that
you know it's kind of what I do but
whatever
um the point is
um you know after that I'm like okay
this is kind of different and then I
engage again maybe a little bit more
sharp and then I get the same thing back
I'm like well look I don't I don't I'm
not I don't want to be the person with a
silky voice that you know people just
let everything go because you know look
how smoothly they engage that's just not
me that's you know even if I wanted to
let me let's face it so I try the other
thing where I'm like okay look I'm just
gonna try I'm gonna try to engage and if
it doesn't work then you know
I've now know something that I feel I
need to engage with to actually like
convey and if I'm wrong again we're
going back to the double click thing
where you're like people are gonna be
like hey are you sure you said I was
like look over there you know and are
you sure he saw it I'm like he commented
on it like he must have seen it right so
here's I'll say one more thing and at
the uh you know at the risk of sort of
over over broadening one thing I learned
during the pandemic is a pattern where
people with large platforms
um will do that we'll we'll make some
claims some claims that are false claims
some people that are some claims that
are defamatory claims right
um and
um they then when when when sort of
construct well-constructed response
comes back whereas like okay you said
this this is not true here's the
evidence here's the receipts whatever
whatever
um they will do the thing where they
don't respond and they kind of run to
Their audience where they make some
claims to you know in the to their home
team and sort of just hope to get away
with it like people with large audiences
you know you can trick yourself right
because hey every all of my followers
are telling me I'm great so it must be
fine
um and and I think that has been toxic
right that's probably what killed the
IDW by America it's been worse than
toxic it is also like an API that lets
the propagandistic enemy capture people
right in other words to the extent that
you are monitoring some audience that is
large enough that you don't know who or
what is in it
right and you are using it as a guide
for whether or not you've got things
right then something that wishes to
steer you can do it with the equivalent
of applause
right I mean I think Eric but it doesn't
even it's not even Nest you know that's
how it's going to happen regardless I
mean sure there's more surreptitious uh
methods that that can be uh employed but
I'm just saying the Natural Forces
people who watch you watch you because
they like you and they have you know
some some uh you know warm feelings
about you so if they're
um if you ask them was I right about
this they're probably going to say yes
and even if they don't agree with you
they're probably not going to say that
so you kind of feel like okay well we're
good and and and really the the fact
that there wasn't a way to actually get
people on a neutral basis to get
together and discuss stuff right with
some sort of neutral-ish like mediator
if need be but like without a platform
Advantage right so even when you know
with Scott Alexander when I got into
this very long conversation how did it
end like he picked out some things he
mixed up some others you know uh sort of
misstated some of my claims to his his
audience and that was that he responded
right what what am I going to do now I
can continue the conversation but it's
gonna end the same way so it's it's
utterly frustrating from the point of
view of the audience right like I I feel
like I'm part of the audience at least
for now to see that play out and you
know sometimes it comes out probably not
in the best ways but that's
um yeah look I I hear you right and it's
not that I don't know that sometimes I
uh you know my my tone is not what I uh
I would like it to be
um but again on on balance like who's
who's is right and I and I don't want to
be fake and people should know that if
they double click uh on stuff we can we
can go further and and I'm always like
my DMs are open and I'm always open to
talk to people yeah absolutely I think
that's fair
um
I wish we lived in a world in which we
all agreed
that a we are all enhanced greatly if we
get to the truth or an approximation of
it whatever it may be and that one
cannot avoid
um
a conflict that it will result in
embarrassment for whichever ones of us
have thought something was true and then
discovered it wasn't but that there's a
basic way that we deal with this I wish
we were all on board with the same
agreement and that you were therefore
being understood
uh to be doing what I understand you to
be doing right understood by others to
be doing that which is right like you're
functioning like
um you know
an attorney in a system in which
adversarial presentations are the
mechanism through which the court
achieves its end right and
um
I think others are involved in different
codes none of which are stated or very
few of them have stated these codes and
so there's a conflict between them but
in any case I would say just from the
point of view of actually getting to
something that approximates the truth in
some form that it is actually hearable
by the maximum number of people I would
say uh
a little bit of caution in how one
presents is
I'm going to pay large dividends
right actually let me let me give you
one example and believe me
as you know I have every reason not to
be particularly inclined to defending
Sam Harris
I did think there was something
instructive though in what went down
with the clips of Sam that you put out
Sam's reaction to them the Public's
reaction to them
um there was one thing in which he I
think in several different clips alluded
to uh
dead children right and it became
interesting like oh Sam Harris has a
dead children tick in some of the things
he said and I looked very carefully at
those clips and I know Sam not terribly
well but well enough
and I'm convinced that what happened
is that Sam uses dead children as his
own it's like a personal trolley problem
formulation right his point is I'm going
to set that slider to maximum even if
this involved dead children
then X still still holds right that is
not about Sam really being comfortable
with dead children in fact the opposite
it's about him recognizing that that
would be the maximum bad thing and that
if you just set that parameter to
maximum it X Y and Z but
it's still evidences even if you
understand that Sam is just using like a
philosophy trick in order to get
somewhere the conclusion is still
jaw-dropping right even if Hunter Biden
had dead children in his basement I
would still X Y and Z that is in and of
itself disturbing right that it wouldn't
cause you to rethink you know even just
the fact of you know a president or
would be president having a son with
dead children in his basement does the
does the would-be president know that
there are dead children in the basement
would that not disturb you right the
point is
wouldn't that disturb you right like any
normal person would be caused to rethink
pull out a fresh sheet of paper and
reevaluate whether or not their feelings
about Joe Biden were the same if they
discovered that Hunter Biden had dead
children in this basement having nothing
to do with your comfort with dead
children right so Sam did reveal a
gaping defect in his model or his
character or both right you revealed it
by putting together a large clip it's
not like you took him out of context
right two minutes and 20 seconds and
whenever I cut Clips by the way
um I I this is I know what algorithm I'm
running because that's how I do it uh if
people want to first of all nobody has
ever said oh yeah I want to listen to
the whole thing and it's better usually
I hear I went and listened the whole
thing and it's worse but
um but see where I made the cuts see if
that is a reasonable place to make the
cuts because Sam Harris again and custom
unfortunately now has taken the same
plot Point
um and they're saying oh you know all
these deceptive Clips okay well how
would you clip it secondly on that tweet
I did not mention the dead children in
that tweet I actually I it didn't that
was not my focus right after that and
after I've been sort of you know flatly
with no right of response or anything
like that right flatly you know across
platforms that have millions and
millions of people people keep calling
Barnes which is a podcast I I really
like and he just called me a piece of
[__] with with no prompting he just
offered that up right about my career
let me just complete this point right
after all of that right
um I I saw this other one and and really
again that was a sequence of Clips there
was one particular tweet where I'm like
all right what is it I mean you you've
been taking the task about this just can
you like stop because I I know what you
mean and I actually partially agree I
think what he is doing is that is an
extreme of a slider but the slider is
not emotional resonance to Sam it is
emotional resonance to other people and
he actually if he's here the other
argument that you know kind of went
viral as well it was he said well if it
had killed children people wouldn't
would have complied meaning if the
impact was the same in terms of deaths
but it was children which you know the
normies kind of get moved by then people
would have complied and and that is the
thrust of that argument and first of all
that is ridiculous like just let's take
the clinical quality adjusted life years
they are non-comparable okay an 85 year
old and a five-year-old are just
different things
um secondly
um like yeah reasons
I mean we can't we can't really even
begin I don't I don't know what's
happened to Sam Harris I think he's a
lot better than that he he's he's he he
perfectly competent of understanding
um why that is a terrible argument to
bring up why that is a terrible argument
to bring out that way regardless I did
my own analysis of that argument I'm
like I I I but ultimately right my
Twitter page is my log where people can
read my thoughts in in the context that
I write them and Will some tweet go
viral I mean I don't know which tweets
go for honestly the tweets I want to go
viral don't and the things the tweets I
don't do right so I don't control that
um I just say what I what I think and
yeah I do think like you know hey if
you've like gone into hot water for that
just like
don't do that anymore but like I do
think he does it because he's trying to
throw out a very bright light to sort of
confuse it's it's a it's a confusing
tactic unfortunately and I don't like to
um uh say that people are uh doing
something uh you know surreptitious or
whatever but like I've I've run it
through my head in many many ways I
can't come up with a better hypothesis
than it is a a thing that is supposed to
cause an emotional reaction in The
Listener not that Sam himself is
particularly I mean look I know he loves
his children I know that he doesn't want
children to die or anything like that
let's get that out of the way but the
the use in argumentation is
um its function at the very least is
such as to distract from The Logical
structure of the argument being made and
if you do a formal analysis which I have
done
um you just yeah it doesn't it doesn't
add anything at all it just well you
just like why would you do that why
would you bring that up it's worse than
that because of course yeah I know it's
worse than that that is a very useful
phrase unfortunately but it's worse than
that because the very
authorities and policies that Sam ended
up defending
put actual children in danger that they
did not need to be exposed to and Sam
went after those of us who tried to get
in the way and protect children so to
the extent that
normies and Sam himself believe that
children deserve some special protection
and that is why their deaths would be
particularly horrifying to people then
the point is this should have resulted
in Sam at the point that he knew that
these policies made no sense
right at the point he realized oh God
actually there is a problem with this
vaccine enough that I don't want any
more of it and that it shouldn't have
been given to children and especially
male children who experience a greater
risk of myocarditis right that should
have caused him to go back and think oh
not only have I been on the wrong side
of that issue but I've actually gone
after people who were on the right side
I've said nasty things about people who
were trying to prevent this and actually
um you know that is that that should
have forced him to an apology that I
have yet to hear
we can we can go down that rabbit hole a
lot I think we're gonna need this
podcast is going to need a warning of
like jump to yeah oh it is gonna need a
warning uh if you're here for the AI
jump to something like 34 minutes in
yeah
you are on Twitter your
uh your handle is at alexandras marinos
M Alexander Sam so it's my sister yes uh
first letter of my last one sorry I
wasn't thinking about spellability at
the time
um anyway Alexander Sam is my uh Twitter
um and I think by the time this goes up
um we're gonna uh me and and Ryan which
who you also uh know are gonna started
uh youtubing on a channel called
bootstrap AI that people can uh find
where we're going to be experimenting
with tools and basically the on the same
vein of like
how can we get more competent uh to use
this thing for her for good
cool and then if that's the question I'm
interested you and Ryan I'm you know of
course
ethically concerned about what you all
get up to but I know it's going to be
fun
no I'm kidding uh Ryan is a an absolute
Gem and um you two together are
lightning in a bottle so I'm I'm excited
about that
um
sub stack you are oh man your your
phrase the the title of your sub stack
has become such a flash point for
civilization do your own research
yeah like you know do your own research
used to be what being a rationalist
meant but apparently
um you know and I chose it tongue and
cheek um and honestly if it turns off
somebody
what are you gonna do about but it's
called do your own research topsack.com
and I've got a lot of pandemic content
on there but I think the latest essay
actually is called
um
I don't remember that but it talks about
um the age of bespoke that's it again
another possible pop possible positive
future that we could find ourselves in
or at least one dimension of the future
that we'll find ourselves ourselves in
which you know depending on everything
else might turn out good or bad but
um
yeah I I try to explore all these
thoughts and and longer form and and
less prickly uh on my sub stack uh do
your own research subject.com
um but um yeah so that's
cool well that's uh that's great
um your sub stack is very cool I'm
looking forward to your YouTube channel
with that Alexander's marinos it has
been an absolute pleasure it is as
always been very enlightening I enjoy
that about you uh it is impossible to
find the uh the full depth of the
thoughts that you have which means
you've always got new stuff to say so
um anyway thanks for for joining me
again on Dark Horse
thank you for everything you do and keep
it up all right uh I'll see you in the
AGI era
all right be well everyone
[Music]
foreign